ALL RIGHTS GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY AND.
WE'RE CERTAINLY LOOKING FORWARD
TO HEARING ALL THE UPDATES THIS
MORNING.
.
AND A HAPPY TO.
HAVE MY CO CHAIR HERE. AS.
MR CHOW WHO IS OBVIOUSLY THE
CHAIR OF PRIVACY AND MISTER
OBERNOLTE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TO.
MISTER CHAD YOU HAVE SOME
COMMENTS
SURE ABSOLUTELY.
WHEREIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. ARM I LET
ME FIRST.
A BEGIN BY THANKING MY CO CHAIR
SOME A MEMBER IRWIN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON CYBERSECURITY
ISSUES AS CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CYBERSECURITY
THROUGHOUT. OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS I'D IS MY HOPE THAT OUR
COMMITTEE SELL COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH WILL CONTINUE TO HELP
KEEP OUR STATE MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. WHAT I MEAN BY
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH?
IS THAT DOW ONE THAT INVOLVES
ALL OF THIS. FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH TO THE
EXECUTIVE FROM THE STATE
GOVERNMENT TO THE FEDERAL AND TO
THE LOCALS AND FROM THE PUBLIC
TO THE PRIVATE.
I BELIEVE WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
A SILO WOULD OPPOSE CHAU. TO IT
A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE SUCH AS
CYBERSECURITY IS NOT THE MOST
EFFICIENT APPROACH.
OUR AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT A
REACTIONARY APPROACH IS NOT A
SUSTAINABLE OPTION IN TODAY'S
WORLD.
WORD NEW CYBER ATTACKS ARE
INEVITABLE EVEN IF YOU HAVE THE
BEST SECURITY.
OUR TEAMS AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WHAT.
SO OVER BOTH SOLUTIONS TO
INSULATE OURSELVES IN THE MODERN
WORLD. THERE ARE MANY WAYS WE
CAN INCREASE OUR DETECTION
CAPABILITIES. IMPROVE OUR
RESPONSES AND MITIGATE THE
HARMS.
IN MANY RESPECTS SOME VERY
EXCITED TO SEE THE STATE'S
DIRECTION UNDER NEW LEADERSHIP
OF DIRECTOR TO HONG. COMMANDED
TRASH AND THE KELSEY SICK
PARTNERSHIP.
I'M ALSO EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT
THE PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN MADE
TO DATE.
YET WE DON'T WANT TO BE
COMPLACENT.
TO THAT END MY PERSONAL GOAL
TODAY AS CHAIR OF THE PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE IS TO ASK THE
PRESENTERS.
TO ADDRESS THE FOLLOWING
QUESTIONS.
FIRST WHAT IS WORKING AND WHAT
IS NOT.
TO HAVE YOUR DEPARTMENT EXPERTS
FOUND ANY TOOLS THAT ARE MISSING
FROM THEIR TEMPLE BOX THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE.
THREE ARE THERE TOOLS AT YOUR
DISPOSAL THAT YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO USE AND FOR AT THE SAME
TIME WHAT OTHER CRITICAL PIECES
OF INFORMATION. THAT WE NEED TO
KNOW AND UNDERSTAND IN THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE GRAPPLE WITH
NEW POLICY QUESTIONS SURROUNDING
CYBER THREATS MOVING FORWARD.
WITHOUT A LOOK FOR TO OUR
DISCUSSION HERE TODAY AND. LET
ME TRY BACK OVER TO MY CULTURE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER URBAN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD
OWE IT HAS BEEN THAT TWO YEARS
SINCE WE'VE GOTTEN TOGETHER IN
THIS FORMAT TO DISCUSS THE STATE
CYBERSECURITY POSTURE AND I'M.
CERTAINLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING ALL THE PROGRESS THAT
HAS BEEN MADE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHALLAN I HAVE BEEN KEPT UP TO
DATE BY THE ADMINISTRATION OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
ESPECIALLY BY MANY OF THOSE
THAT ARE LISTED TO SPEAK TODAY.
CYBERSECURITY IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST THREATS BOTH THE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SECTOR. AND WILL
ONLY LOOM LARGER AS MORE AND
MORE OF OUR DAILY LIVES RELY ON
A INTERNET CONNECTED DEVICES AND
CLOUD STORAGE.
EFFECTIVE CYBERSECURITY PROGRAM
STANDARDS AND LEADERSHIPS HAS
TAKEN A.
DESERVE IT PROMINENT POSITION
AS THE CORNERSTONE OF STATE
GOVERNMENT.
MY VISION FOR TODAY'S HEARING IS
THAT WE WILL HEAR FROM
CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY LEADERS
ABOUT THE WORK THAT THEY HAVE
UNDERTAKEN TO BRING OUR
CYBERSECURITY POSTURE TO WHERE
IT NEEDS TO BE. AND HOW THEY
PLAN TO MAKE OUR STATE THE
LEADER.
WHEN IT COMES TO CYBERSECURITY
AND WE DO HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF BERMAN WHO HAS JOINED US TO
DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR.
ALRIGHT BUT WE APPRECIATE YOU
JOINING US THIS MORNING AND WITH
THAT WE WILL.
CALL UP OUR FIRST PANEL.
WE HAVE.
DIRECTOR KILLER DUDE SHE.
DIRECTOR AMY TONG.
ADJUTANT GENERAL BALDWIN AND A
CH P. COMMISSIONER STANLEY.
THANK YOU ALL OF US FOR.
JOINING.
.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY. AND A PIPE
WOULD ASK ALL OF YOU TO KEEP
YOUR. COMMENTS TO TEN MINUTES TO
MAKE SURE THAT SAID THAT ALL
MEMBERS WILL BE ABLE TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS THAT.
THAT THEY HAVE SO WHY DON'T WE
START WITH THE AYE DIRECTOR
GULAR DUDE SHE. COULD WELL DONE
AND GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY AND GET QUITE FRANKLY.
IT'S QUITE AN HONOR FOR ME BE
SITTING AT THE TABLE SUCH GREAT
LEADERS THAT WE HAVE.
THAT I GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH. ALL THE TIME.
I KNOW TODAY WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT CYBERSECURITY AYE I
MIGHT GIVE A COUPLE OF AN OVER
ARCHING AND THEN.
THE MY PARTNERS YOU'RE GOING TO
TALK A BIT MORE IN DETAIL ABOUT.
THERE ARE SPECIFIC ROLES.
.
I GUESS FIRST AND FOREMOST AS
HAS YOU SAID IN YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS THE ISSUE OF THE THREAT
OF CYBER TO. OUR STATE AND OUR
COUNTRY REMAINS HIGH.
IT'S REALLY FROM A SECURITY
STANDPOINT ARE IN THE NUMBER A
TOP FIVE OF.
OF OF SECURITY THREATS THAT WE
HAVE.
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN THAT IN
OUR COUNTRY.
AND THOSE THREATS CONTINUE TO
BE FROM A MULTITUDE OF SOURCES
EVERYTHING FROM NATION STATES TO
DOMESTIC SOURCES.
ORGANIZED CRIME.
OR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN DOING HARM.
BOB AS YOU SAID JUST TWO YEARS
AGO.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING SINCE TWO
YEARS AGO WITH A WORKING ON A
PRETTY COLLABORATIVE AND AND I
EXTENSIVE.
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THIS CYBER
THREAT THAT WE'RE FACING AS A
STATE. ARM BY DOING A COUPLE OF
KEY AREAS A ONE IS BUILDING
RESILIENCY AND EDUCATION WHICH.
DIRECTOR TOM WILL TALK ABOUT.
IN IN WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IN
WORK THAT THIS BODY HAS ALSO
HELPED US TO BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE.
OUR AND THEN THE OTHER ONE HAS
BEEN BUILDING.
A CYBER BY DEFENSE CAPABILITY.
WHICH INCLUDES RECOGNITION
INTERDICTION AND MITIGATION.
ARE THAT ALL HAS BEEN ABLE TO
BE.
ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
ISSUED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN WHICH ACTUALLY CREATED
THAT. CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER ARE THIS
CENTER THIS INTEGRATED CENTRE.
WHICH IS CO LOCATED WITH OUR
STATE THREAT ASSESSMENT CENTER.
ARE IS YEAH IS A CENTER WHERE.
WHERE?
A NUMBER OF THE ENTITIES WHICH
HISTORICALLY HAD BEEN DOING
WORK.
SORT OF INDIVIDUALLY ARE TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS CYBER CHALLENGES
IN CALIFORNIA. NOW BRINGS THESE
ENTITIES TOGETHER AND REALLY THE
CORE PARTNERS THAT YOU SEE.
SITTING HERE IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
TO CALIFORNIA HARPER TROLL รณ
YES AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT MILITARY. ARE COME
TOGETHER AS THE CORE PARTNERS I
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS.
ARE THE CONCERNS THAT THAT WERE
FACING AND IN TWO YEARS. ARM
FROM THE TIME WE SET FORTH.
WE.
ESTABLISH A CYBERSECURITY TASK
FORCE WHICH INCLUDES.
OF BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE AND
NON GOVERNMENTAL PARTICIPATION
THIS IS A ADVISORY. SORT OF
GROUP THAT COMES TOGETHER AND
PROVIDES US IN GOVERNMENT IDEAS
AND.
INFORMATION ON BEST PRACTICES
AND HELPS THE GUIDE OUR WAY WE
TAKE THAT INFORMATION AND WE
BUILD THAT IN. TO THE
OPERATIONAL CONSTRUCTS THAT WE
HAVE ARE UNDER THE CAL SICK.
THAT CALCIUM.
OF. YOU IN THIS LAST COUPLE
YEARS EACH OF THE RESPECTIVE OF
ORGANIZATIONS HERE HAVE PLUGGED
PEOPLE IN FULL TIME. OF THOSE
FOLKS ARE LOOKING AT THREAT
STREAMS THAT ARE COMING ACROSS.
THEY'RE WORKING CLOSELY IN
CONCERT WITH EACH OTHER BUT ALSO
WERE WORKING UP BEYOND THE CORE
PARTNERS WITH A NUMBER OF
EXTERNAL PARTNERS INCLUDING
DEPARTMENT HOMELAND SECURITY THE
FBI.
THE COAST GUARD OUR ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS AT UCC ISSUE IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES
UTILITIES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THE BANKING INDUSTRY.
IT'S BEEN A PHENOMENAL AMOUNT
OF EFFORT THAT THE TEAM MEMBERS
HERE TOGETHER.
WHEN I SAW TALKED TWENTY ONE
FIGHT EVERYBODY WORKING ON A
COMMON SET OF OBJECTIVES. OUGHT
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS.
THE TH THE THREAT. I'M WE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY PILOTED.
A WHAT I WOULD CALL WHAT WE
CALL A CYBER THREAT INTELLIGENCE
MACHINE TO MACHINE FEE PROGRAM.
WERE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT.
INCOMING.
AYE DATA AND AND LOOKING FOR
CERTAIN KINDS OF ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE GOING ON IN THOSE STREAMS.
THAT WOULD INDICATOR BE
INDICATORS FOR SOMETHING
POTENTIALLY ARE HAPPENING IN OUR
NETWORK AND THEN OUR DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY.
IS LOOKING AT OF COURSE THE
STATE NETWORKS ARE TO PARK OUR
CALIFORNIA PATROL IS LOOKING AT
THE FORENSICS AND THE CRIMINAL
PREDICATE. AND IN THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENTS DOING THERE
PHENOMENAL JOB DOING ASSESSMENTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
BASELINE. BY WHICH WERE WORKING
ON.
WE EXPECT HAVE FULL MACHINE THE
MACHINE PARTNERS IN BANKING
HEALTHCARE EDUCATION UTILITIES
PRIVATE. SECTOR ORGANIZATIONS
AND SEVERAL OTHER PUBLIC SECTOR
GROUPS I'M REALLY AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL UP BY JANUARY
OF OF NINETEEN.
WHICH WILL BRING US TO REALLY
KIND OF A FULL STRENGTH.
.
IN ADDITION THIS MONTH WE WE
WE'VE ALL BEEN ABLE TO COMPLETE
OF WHAT WE CALL THE JOINT CYBER
INCIDENT. COMMUNICATION
FRAMEWORK AS WELL AS OUR ADJOINT
CYBER INCIDENT RESPONSE GUIDE
EASIER TO.
ELEMENTS THAT PLUGIN TO THE WAY
THE STATE. OF RESPONSE TO.
THESE KINDS OF THREATS.
AND IT SPEAKS TO HOW OUR
INTELLIGENCE NETWORKS.
OUR AND OUR CYBER.
PARTNERS ALL ARE LOOKING AT.
A COMMON SET OF.
ITEMS THREATS AND THEN BEING
ABLE TO CONNECT THE DOTS BY
WHICH.
CERTAIN ACTORS ARE ARE
IDENTIFIED.
AND WE COULD THEN BE OUT IN
FRONT OF EVOLVING CRISIS NOW I
WOULD JUST TELL YOU.
ARE WE AT A HUNDRED PERCENT WHAT
WE NEED TO BE AT NOW WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK THIS IS
EVOLVING THREAT. IT'S CHANGING
EVERY DAY WHICH MEANS THAT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO PAVE IT AND
CHANGE WITH IT. THAT MEANS THAT
TO BE VERY MUCH. OF WORKING
CLOSELY TOGETHER TRIED TO
ANTICIPATE.
USING WHATEVER TECHNOLOGY THAT
WE CAN TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN SEE
THE THREATS THAT ARE COMING
FORWARD AND AND.
.
THE PARTNERS HERE TODAY WILL
WILL TAKE THE TIME TO TO TALK
ABOUT THAT.
.
ON THE BOARD HERE YOU SEE SOME
OF THAT THE VARIOUS UP PARTNERS
THAT WE HAVE.
TIED IN WITH US AT THE REALLY
THESE ARE THAT THE DATA DAY
PARTNERS THAT WE'RE GETTING.
AND WORKING IN COLLABORATION
WITH.
WHERE?
?
ALL OF THOSE ENTITIES BRING A
POWERFUL SANDOVAL OF
CAPABILITIES TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA. ARE IS IN A PLACE
WHERE.
WE WE REMAIN OUT IN FRONT OF
THIS UP THIS THREAD IN DEPTH.
YOU'LL ARE TODAY ABOUT SOME
VERY STE VERY SIGNIFICANT ALL
WINS THAT WE HAVE HAD.
THAT THAT I DON'T BELIEVE WE
WOULD HAVE HAD JUST TWO YEARS
AGO IN BEING ABLE TO ENTER
DECKED. US IT VERY SEVERE ARE
THREATS TO THE STATE AND STATE
NETWORKS.
WHICH PREVENTED US AS A STATE
OF FROM BEING IN A VERY.
TOUGH PLACE.
PRIVATE CHANGE THE OF SLIDE.
.
THE GENERAL A SENSE OF AWE OF
THE CUP OF THE CYBERSECURITY
IMMIGRATION CENTER.
AS YOU CAN SEE THE COR PARTNERS.
AND THEN THE PARTNER AGENCIES
IT IS A IT IS A A UP PUSH AND
PULL SYSTEM WHERE EVERY. WHERE
FEEDS OF INFORMATION ARE FLOWING
IN ARE COMING INTO THE?
CAL SICK EACH AND EVERY DAY AND.
IF FROM LOCAL STATE PRIVATE AND
FEDERAL.
THAT'S VERTICAL AND HORIZONTAL
AND.
THOSE THOSE THAT INFORMATION IS
ASSESSED.
EIGHT IS ASSESSED AGAINST
THREATS STREAMS AND INTELLIGENCE
THAT WE GET ARE FROM THE VARIOUS
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES TO IT TO
TRY TO DETERMINE. ARM WHERE THE
THREATS ARE COMING FROM
OBVIOUSLY CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROTECTION IS OF
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE TO
PORTANTINO EYES. ARE AND AND WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
SIGNATURES FROM CERTAIN.
NATION STATE ACTORS THAT WERE
LOOKING FOR BUT ALSO.
AND THE CHALLENGES WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN.
INDIVIDUALS HACKTIVIST
ACTIVISTS OR ORGANIZED CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS BEING ABLE TO COME
IN AND WANTED TO DO.
WHETHER IT'S AS STEALING FINDS
OR.
DOING RANSOMWARE TAX LAW OR
SIMPLY OF PHISHING EMAILS.
THAT THAT THAT BE PUSHED OUT
INTO THE SYSTEM WHERE WE ARE
SEEING.
AYE THE ABILITY OF GETTING INTO
OUR NETWORKS ALL OF THAT.
ALL OF THAT IS IS A IS A MUCH
MORE COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW AND
THROUGH A EFFORTS BY MY PARTNERS
THAT ARE GONNA BE SPEAKING IN A
FEW MINUTES.
I COULD TELL YOU THAT THERE'S
BEEN A CONCERTED EFFORT HAS BEEN
BETTER EDUCATION THERE'S BEEN
BETTER TRAINING. AND WE'VE WE'VE
BOLSTERED SO WITH THAT I WILL.
STOP ALTERNATE OVER TO.
.
NOW THE NEXT BEAKER AND AND.
HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS WHEN
YOU'RE RIGHT AND WE WILL ANSWER.
ASK QUESTIONS.
AFTER ALL EVERYBODY SPEAKS
DIRECTOR TOM.
ALRIGHT I GOOD MORNING I OTHERS
THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR CO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR GIVING
THIS OPPORTUNITY.
AS SAID RIDE I DIRECTOR GARY
DUE TO MENTION.
THE HONORED ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES
TO PRESENT TO YOU THE PROGRESS
DIVE WE ARE VERY PROUD OF.
YOU KNOW ON THE CYBERSECURITY
FRONT
AND DODD.
I DIDN'T DIRECTOR GARRETT
RICHIE HAS A GIVEN NOTE A VERY
GOOD OVERVIEW IN TERM OF THE THE
ROLE AND RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
COURT FOR COR PARTNERS.
RANGING FROM CAL SICK BEING THE
OVERALL INFORMATION HUB AND DATA
SHARING AND INTELLIGENCE SHARING
AND COORDINATING.
AREA TO DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY SPECIFICALLY FOCUSING
ON THE STATE'S TECHNOLOGY
OPERATION INFRASTRUCTURE WHERE
CYBERSECURITY YOU KNOW STANDARD
NEEDS TO BE APPLY. AND DODD
SIMPLY TECHNOLOGY STANDARD ALSO
NEED TO BE ASSOCIATED TO THAT
WITH CYBERSECURITY DEFENSE AS
THE TOP OF MIND.
IN ADDITION TO THE OUTSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY ALSO HAS A
SINK ROLE IN THE POLICY
DEVELOPMENT PROCEDURE
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS EDUCATION
TO THE STATE'S GENERAL STATE
STOP A PUBLIC.
STAFF.
IN RAISING AWARENESS AND GIVING
THEM TOOLS TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
FROM A CYBERSECURITY THREATS.
THE THIRD COMPONENT DIED.
DOES DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY.
ALSO IS TASKED TO DO IT'S A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FOR THE IT
CLASSIFICATION.
AS YOU HAVE LIED TO HOLD
PREVIOUS CONVERSATION BEFORE THE
IN ORDER TO SUSTAIN DECEMBER
SECURITY DEFENSE.
RELYING ON AUTOMATED TOOL IS ONE
THING LOT OF IT IT'S THE HUMAN
FACTOR OF IT AND THE HUMAN
FACTOR YOU KNOW SPEND THROUGH
BOTH. THE USER WHICH IS
EDUCATION TO THEM AS WELL AS A
GOOD CYBERSECURITY SPECIALIST
THAT COULD BE YOU KNOW WORKING
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OR
PUBLIC SECTOR IN GENERAL. IN
PROTECTING OUR MOST VALUABLE
ASSET.
ALL THREE OF THOSE AREA
OPERATION POLICY AND WORK FIRST
DEVELOPMENT.
YOU CAN HEAR MORE ELABORATION
AND SPECIFIC EXAMPLES ON THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE ACCOMPLISHED
IN THAT YEAR'S LAST YEAR TOO
FROM PANEL NUMBER TWO SALSA SAVE
ALL INTO. THEM DIP DUG THE GOOD
EXAMPLES FOR THEM TO ELABORATE
ON.
BUT I DO WANT TO ECOLE.
DIRECTOR.
GARY DO SHE SENTIMENT DIED. THE
COLLABORATION AMONGST A CORE FOR
HERE AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL PARK
PARTNERS SO YOU HAVE SEEN MADE A
HUGE DIFFERENCE IN TERM OF. THE
WHAT USED TO BE A SILO APPROACH
IN ADDRESSING CYBERSECURITY
NEEDS AND COLLABORATING WITH THE
HIGHWAY PATROL WHEN INCIDENTS
HAPPENED THEIR IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE AND IF IT CRIMINAL.
INVESTIGATION IS IT'S WARRANTED
IT'S VERY FAST AND IN TERMS OF.
GETTING ENGAGED AND HELP TO YOU
KNOW STOP RIGHT THERE IN WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF MILITARY
THE INDEPENDENT.
A SALSA SUSSMAN ANSWER
INDEPENDENT OF SECURITY
ASSESSMENT BEING CONDUCTED BY
DEPARTMENT OF.
MILITARY GAVE US ALL OF US IN
ADDITIONAL LENDS A PERSPECTIVE
ON HOW AND INDIVIDUALS TO
ENTITIES ARE DOING WHICH HELPS
COMPLETE DOT COMPREHENSIVE
EVALUATION. ON HOW DEPARTMENTS
ARE DOING TODAY OF WHAT TYPE OF
MEASURE NEEDS TO BE IN PLACE TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE CYBERSECURITY
STAND.
AGAIN AND WITH THE.
MAIN FOCUS HERE IS TO DEAL WITH
INCIDENT WHEN WE COME UP IN A
SWIFTLY WAY. WORKING WITH FAR
PARTNER AND IN BETWEEN INCIDENTS
DIED WORKING TO DICK TOGETHER TO
PRO ACTIVELY EDUCATE AND
MATURING THE STATE ENTITIES
SECURITY MEASURE IS THE GOAL OF
HUMBLE ITS FORESTS DISPUESTOS
STRATEGY OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO. IN CYBERSECURITY DEFENSE.
I WILL.
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTION.
BUT ALSO DIED WOULD.
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE WHICH IS
CHIEF DEPUTY CHRIS CREWS AS WELL
AS THE CHIEF INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICER PETER LEAVER.
COMING UP IN THE PANEL TO DATE
PROVIDE THE PANEL MORE SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES OF THOSE EFFORTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH DIRECTOR
TONGUE AND DOES GENERAL BALDWIN.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANKS FOR
INCLUDING US TODAY. AYE WE'VE
SPOKEN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE.
THE.
CYBERSECURITY THREATS AND YOU
KNOW THE MILITARY WE. CATEGORIZE
THREATS INTO TWO MAIN BUCKETS
I'M WE TALK ABOUT ASYMMETRIC
THREATS OF THINGS LIKE CRIMINALS
AND TERRORISTS ORGANIZATIONS AND
WE TALK ABOUT NEAR PEER
COMPETITORS WHICH OUR NATION
STATE ACTORS THAT HAVE. MILITARY
CAPABILITY THAT THREATENS ARE
CAPABLE OUR MILITARY CAPABILITY
TO DEFEND THIS NATION AND DEFEND
U. S. INTERESTS AROUND THE
GLOBE.
BUT WE STILL HAVE OVER MATCH IN
MANY AREAS.
MILITARILY THE ONE EXCEPTION IS
IN CYBER IN CYBER. ALMOST
EVERYONE THAT WE ENCOUNTER THEIR
ADVERSARIES.
ARE PURE COMPETITORS THERE
REALLY GOOD THE GOOD NEWS IS WE
TOO ARE VERY GOOD AT DEFENDING
OUR NETWORKS AND FINING THESE
PROBLEMS BUT IT IS A HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE DOMAIN. THAT IS
CONSTANTLY EVOLVING AND WE IN
CONSTANTLY HAVE TO STAY ON OUR
TOES.
TO BE ABLE TO DETECT AND DEFEAT
THREATS TO OUR NETWORKS.
THE GOOD NEWS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE SEEN A RAPID RAPID
IMPROVEMENT IN THE INTER AGENCY
COOPERATION AND OUR ABILITY TO
COLLECTIVELY. DEFEND OUR
NETWORKS LARGELY THROUGH THE
LEADERSHIP OF DIRECTOR TONG AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
AND DIRECTOR GUILTY CHEAT รณ WE
ASK THAT REALLY WHO BROUGHT US
TOGETHER. TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
EACH DEPARTMENT OR AGENCIES
UNIQUE CAPABILITIES AND
STRENGTHS TO MAKE THE WHOLE
TEAM.
BETTER WITHIN THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT WE'VE EXPANDED THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE ON
OUR FULL TIME COMPUTER NETWORK
DEFENSE TEAM. FROM EIGHT TO
NINETEEN SO THAT HAS
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVED OUR REACH
TO BE OF THE ABLE TO US DO
ASSESSMENTS NOT ONLY WITHIN.
STATE AGENCIES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT NOW ALSO
REACHING DOWN TO SOME COUNTIES
TO ASSIST COUNTIES WITH THEM
PROTECTION OF THEIR NETWORKS AND
INTO THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS.
WE HAVE SIX PEOPLE IN ADDITION
THAT WORK FULL TIME AT THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER WHOSE MAIN
TASK IS TO HELP PROTECT
THE STATE DATA CENTER. TO WATCH
FOR THREATS THERE AND WE HAVE
TWO SOLDIERS THAT ARE EMBEDDED.
IN THE COW SICK THE PROVIDE A
INTO CYBER INTELLIGENCE SUPPORT.
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CHP AND THE FBI WHEN THERE ARE
CYBER INCURSION CASES OR CYBER
CRIMES. TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST
WITH CYBER FORENSICS
AND THEN FINALLY WE HAVE A TEAM
OF THIRTY NINE SOLDIERS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ON FEDERAL DUTY AT U.
S. CYBER COMMAND PERFORMING
THEY'RE ABOUT TO COME OFF OF
THAT DEPLOYMENT THEY'LL RETURN
HERE TO CALIFORNIA AND TEN OF
THOSE SOLDIERS WILL BE FULL TIME
AND THEY'LL BE AVAILABLE AS WELL
AS A PART TIME PEOPLE.
WE HAVE A PRETTY.
WE'RE DEVELOPING A FAIRLY
ROBUST
BENCH SO IN ADDITION TO OURFULL
TIME SEVERAL WARRIORS THAT ARE
DOING THINGS FOR THE STATE. WE
CAN REACH INTO OUR PART TIME
ARMY AND AIR NATIONAL GUARD
CYBER ORGANIZATIONS AND BRING
THOSE TALENTED INDIVIDUALS WHO
BRING NOT ONLY THEIR WAR
FREDERIK SKILLS. BUT SINCE
THEY'RE PART TIME ALMOST ALL OF
THEM WORK IN CYBER FIELDS IN
THEIR CIVILIAN JOBS AND THEY
BRING UNIQUE SKILL SET SO WE CAN
BRING THEM ON FOR. SHORT PERIODS
OF TIME EITHER TO DO ASSESSMENTS
TO HELP TO TRAINING OR TO HELP.
.
DO FORENSIC WORK IN THE EVENT OF
A CYBER INTRUSION.
SO WE ARE.
REALLY PUTTING A BIG EFFORT
TOWARDS THIS IS ONE OF MY TOP
PRIORITIES BECAUSE AS I
MENTIONED THIS IS THE ONLY
DOMAIN WHERE WE DON'T OVER MATCH
OUR ADVERSARIES EVERYONE ELSE IN
THE WORLD IS JUST AS GOOD AS
THAT AT AS WE ARE.
THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT WE'RE
GOOD AT DEFENDING THEIR GOOD
ATTACKING AND WE HAVE TO STAY ON
OUR TOES AND HAPPILY AGAIN WITH
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE PEOPLE
SITTING HERE. ON THE STATE'S AND
PRETTY GOOD HANDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND.
COMMISSIONER STANLEY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN CHURCHTOWN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR AND I'M
HERE TO COME BEFORE YOU SPEAK.
ON THIS TOPIC WITH THE OUR
PARTNERS HERE AT THE TABLE. I
JUST WANT TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE CHP ZERO ONE AND WHAT
WE'VE DONE. IN COLLABORATION
WITH THEIR OUR PARTNERS HERE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS I HAVE BEACH
OVER RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY. CYBER
ATTACKED OR CYBER CRIME THAT
OCCURS TO THE STATE AGENCY A
STATE ENTITY OUR STATE FACILITY.
AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE WE PUT TOGETHER
WHAT WE CALL OUR COMPUTER CRIMES
INVESTIGATION UNIT.
THAT UNIT IS COMPRISED OF A
LIEUTENANT A SERGEANT.
SEVEN INVESTIGATORS INTO IT
SYSTEMS SPECIALIST AND THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR INVESTIGATING
CYBERCRIMES BUT ALSO THEY WORK
VERY WELL. WITH OUR PARTNERS
HERE AT THE TABLE AND PARTNERS.
THAT YOU THAT YOU SEE UP THERE.
ONE OF THOSE INVESTIGATORS IS
ASSIGNED TO THE.
THAT CALIFORNIA'S CYBERSECURITY
SECURITY IMMIGRATION CENTER.
SO WHAT HAVE BEEN THAT
INVESTIGATORS THERE. THERE'S A
GREAT DEAL OF INFORMATION
SHARING INFORMATION
DISSEMINATION AND A LOT OF
COORDINATION THAT IS. I BELIEVE
THIS DIRECTOR YOU WOULD DO TO
YOU MY PARTNER SAID.
HAVE IMPROVE IMPROVE DATA THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO
DEAL WITH CYBER THREATS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
ALSO.
R. CC AYE YOU DOES IS THEY WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE FBI CYBER
CRIMES TASK FORCE HEARING
SACRAMENTO SO HELPLESS. AND WITH
THEM THERE'S SOME FEDERAL ASSETS
THAT WE CAN WORK WITH AND ALSO
WORKING WITH. A GENERAL BALDWIN
AND THAT HIS STAFF WHICH IS ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT.
AS DIRECTOR GIVE A DIGI SAID WE
WE COME A LONG WAY AND WE MADE A
LOT A LOT OF VERY VERY GOOD
PROGRESS. IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AND.
I JUST LIKE BEING BY SAYING
THAT.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE WHAT WE'RE
DOING BURKE WERE WORKING
TOGETHER.
THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE AND
I'M VERY VERY HAPPY ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF PROGRESS WE'VE MADE IN
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMISSIONER.
A QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I HAVE A
QUESTION PUBLIC FOR DIRECTOR
TONG.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S NO
SUCH THING AS THE PERFECT SIDERS
CYBERSECURITY BUT.
THAT IT'S GOING TO CONTINUALLY
BE ATTENTION BETWEEN THE
AGGRESSORS AS NEW
VULNERABILITIES ARE IDENTIFIED
AS COMPUTING POWER NETWORK
BANDWIDTH INCREASE.
AND THEN.
THE DEFENDERS.
AS.
THOSE VULNERABILITIES ARE
IDENTIFIED AND FIXED AND AS NEW
TACTICS AND.
AND NEW BAD ACTORS ARE
IDENTIFIED SO.
THE BALANCE OF POWER'S GOING TO
SHIFT BACK AND FORTH I'M CURIOUS
AS TO YOUR OPINION.
WHETHER WE ARE.
WE'RE WINNING THE BATTLE OF
WERE A LITTLE BIT BEHIND HER
WERE ABOUT THE SAME PLACE WHERE
WE WERE TWO YEARS AGO WITH
ERRORS IN RESPECT OF THOSE
THINGS.
AND I WOULD DIE I I PROBABLY
WON'T PUT DEED OPINION ON
WHETHER WE ARE. WINNING OR
LOSING ABOUT OR OR EVEN BUT I
CAN CITE DOT SPECIFICALLY.
WOULD YOU HAVE CITED THE THAT
THERE'S TWO PRONGED APPROACH
WERE OR WERE IMPLEMENTING AND
AND AND IS HAVE SEEN GREAT
RESULTS FROM IT. NUMBER ONE AS I
MENTIONED DIED.
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGIES TOSSED
TO SAID THE TECHNOLOGY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE STANDARD FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON THAT AND
WE HAVE RECENTLY.
STOOD UP A.
A HYBRID CLOUD SERVICE WHICH
AGAIN THAT WOULD BE ELABORATE
FURTHER OUGHT TO DEFINE A VERY
HIGH STANDARD OF A SECURITY
MEASURE AND AND AND AND AND.
AND I'LL PUT THAT INTO A POLICY
AS A WAY FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
STAND STATE ENTITY THAT YOUR
WHOLE LIFE SEEING THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE NETWORK
CONNECTION TO MEET THAT
PARTICULAR STANDARD. AND THAT'S
A PROACTIVE WAY TOO IF YOU WOULD
SAFEGUARD YOU KNOW THAT THE
INFORMATION HIGHWAY THAT WHICH
PROBABLY ON AS A WAY OF.
PUTTING ADDITIONAL.
A CHALLENGES FOR ANY OF THE
ATTACKERS WANTS TO COME IN THAT
IS NUMBER ONE FROM A POLICY AND
PROCEDURE PROSPECTIVE. NUMBER
TWO.
WE HAVE BUT A STOOD UP THE
FIRST EVER TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
CYBERSECURITY OPERATIONS CENTER
FOR THE STATE DATA CENTER.
DOT IS A WORKING IN CONJUNCTION
WITH CAL SIGNAL THE PARTNER HERE
THAT PROVIDES TO THE E. OF VANCE
MONITORING TO A VERY SPECIFIC
LEVEL TO PRO ACTIVELY WATCHING
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THAT
TRANSITION OF A CONNECTIVITY.
AND INFORMATION SHARING AND WITH
THAT KIND OF A MONITORING AND A
HIGH STANDARD FROM THE NETWORK
PERSPECTIVE WE BELIEVE THOSE ARE
TWO.
FAIRLY.
FOR ACTIVE MEASURES INFORMATION
SECURITY MOONLIGHT
DOLLAR HIS THINK YOU'VE SEEN OFF
TIME IS KEEPING UP WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH.
ALL OF THE.
.
YOU KNOW MEASURES IN PLACE HELPS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO BE A
STEP AHEAD IF NOT SWITCHED UP AT
LEAST HALF A STEP AHEAD.
SETTING THE STANDARD SETTING THE
POLICY IMPLEMENTING THOSE POLICY
AND THEN PRACTICALLY MONITORING.
SO THAT'S FOR OUR.
.
APPROACH IN ADDRESSING.
THANK YOU ARE BUT YOU'RE DOING
GREAT WORK.
I WONDER THOUGH IF WE SHOULDN'T
BE LOOKING AT SOME METRICS TO
TRY AND IDENTIFY WHETHER OR NOT
WE'RE WINNING OR LOSING BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN
ORGANIZATION YOU SUCKED GOALS.
YOU SET PROCEDURES FROM MEETING
THOSE GOALS I THINK WE ALSO NEED
TO BE RETROSPECTIVE AND.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE DONE
AND SEE IF WE BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
DOING AFFECTED PRESENT NOT
EFFECTIVE OR YOU KNOW AND AND
LET US GUIDE LETTERS USE THOSE
METRICS TO GUIDE FUTURE
DECISIONS SO.
THE I WONDER IF THERE ISN'T
SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
OUT OF NOT NUMBER OF BREACHES OR
THE AMOUNT OF DATA THAT'S BEEN
COMPROMISED OR SOMETHING OR SOME
SORT OF METRIC. THE TRIES TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE
WINNING A REAL LOSING OR GAINING
GROUND I THINK THERE WILL BE
FRUITFUL IN IDENTIFYING OTHER
PATHS THAT MAYBE WE NEED TO
ADDRESS.
THANK YOUR FOR THAT SEGUE DOT
HEIGHT I DID NEGLECT TO MENTION
THAT.
.
THINK WAS LITERALLY TWO WEEKS
AGO.
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE ISSUED OUR TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN ANNUAL REPORT.
AND THE ANNUAL REPORT ITSELF.
I WISH I BROUGHT A COPY WITH ME
I WILL MAKE SURE THAT A COPIES
DELIVERED TO ALL THE MEMBERS
COMMITTEE. THAT HAVE LOW HUGE
PAGE NOT HUGE GREAT TWO PAGES
FOR OF.
METRICS
THE ARE RANGING NOT JUST A
CYBERSECURITY RELATED MATRIX
THAT WAS BUILDING UPON TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN'S PERFORMED
METRICS BUT ALSO.
HAVE METRICS ON THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SIDE OF THINGS THE
PROJECT MANAGEMENT SIDE OF
THINGS AND THE TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE UTILIZATION THIS
CENTER SECTION STANDARDIZATION
SIDE OF THINGS SO YES WE ARE
HEAVILY.
USING THOSE PERFORMANCE METRICS
TO GUIDE HERSELF AND ASHURA
PROGRESS BUT WERE ALSO CONTINUE
TO EVOLVE THOSE METRICS TO
BETTER CAPTURED YOU KNOW WHAT
TRUE MEASUREMENT CAN BE PUT IN
PLACE TO BETTER ABOUT.
YOU KNOW MEASURE PROGRESS
SO BASED ON THOSE METRICS WOULD
YOU SAY WERE MAKING PROGRESS.
BASED ON THIS METRIC COMPARED TO
DAWSON SEVEN TWO TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WOULD DEFINITELY MAKING
PROGRESS
IT'S GOOD TO HEAR THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAP ARM I JUST
OF A BROAD QUESTION AND A WHEN
IT COMES TO PREPAREDNESS TO AS A
STATE AGAINST A CYBER ATTACKS
ON.
HOW DO WE STACK UP AGAINST
OTHER STATES IN THE COUNTRY ON?
ANYONE WHO GOING THEY ARE FAKE
THE QUESTION I.
YOU KNOW.
ALL ALL THE STATE'S OBVIOUSLY
HAVE A CYBER THREAT.
SO SOME MORE THAN OTHERS AND IT
DEPENDS ON THE.
IT DEPENDS ON THE.
CYBER ACTOR AND WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR OBVIOUSLY
CALIFORNIA.
GIVEN ITS RICH.
ECONOMY AND ITS INDUSTRIAL BASE
YOU KNOW WE ARE. A HUGE TARGET
FOR.
FOR EXAMPLE ESPIONAGE IN BEING
ABLE TO GET.
BUSINESS.
AT BUSINESS ADVANTAGE.
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT STATES OF
OUR.
ACTIVELY PURSUING SOME SORT OF
CYBER DEFENSE CAPABILITY.
BUT.
THERE'S ONLY ONLY A HANDFUL
THAT HAVE ACTUALLY GOTTEN TO A
PLACE WHERE WE ARE OUT IN
CALIFORNIA AND DOUBT WE WERE
CLOSELY.
WITH.
THE VARIOUS OTHER INTELLIGENCE
NETWORKS IN THE COUNTRY.
AND AND THOSE INTELLIGENCE NET
THOSE INTELLIGENCE CENTERS ARE
WORKING WITH THE WITH THE CYBER
UNITS THAT THEY ARE PUTTING IN
PLACE BUT. I THINK YOU KNOW.
THERE'S PROBABLY SEVEN OR EIGHT
STATES NOW THAT HAVE REALLY
STARTED TO BUILD.
CAPACITY LIKE WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE IN WEEK AND WE'RE
LEARNING FROM THEM AS WELL SOME
OF THE HAVE SOME GOOD IDEAS.
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT
INCORPORATING IN THE AND THEY'RE
TAKING OBVIOUSLY FOR MONTHS IT
IS A IT IS THE IT IS REALLY
BUILT ON THIS COLLABORATIVE.
SHARING OF INFORMATION PLATFORM
AND AS FAR AS THE FREQUENCY AND
SEVERITY OF THE CYBER ATTACKS SO
WOULD YOU SAY THAT CALIFORNIA'S
BEING SINGLED OUT OR. IS
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE FEW STATES
THAT.
ABOUT ACTORS TEND TO TARGET OF
FOR EXAMPLE.
I WOULD NOT I WOULD NOT I CAN
WE SPEAK TO WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE
BEAN.
SINGLE BALLOT I I WOULD I WOULD
SAY TO YOU THAT YOU KNOW THERE
IS NOT A DAY THAT GOES BY THAT
WE DO NOT HAVE A CYBER INTRUSION
OUR CYBER ATTACK OF SOME SORT.
YOU ONLY REALLY HEAR ABOUT THE
ONES THAT YOU KNOW THEY GET TO
THE MEDIA THERE. THIS TEAM ARE
AND THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
SITTING IN FRONT OF YOU ARE
WORKING. WE NIGHT DAY AND THEY
ARE MITIGATING A LOT OF THE
STUFF THAT'S COMING IN THROUGH.
BUT.
IT BE AS THE AS THE GENERAL
SAID THIS IS THIS IS A THIS IS A
NON YOU KNOW NONSTOP KINDA DEAL
AND IT REQUIRES. THAT TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN THREE SIXTY FIVE
ENGAGEMENT.
I I WOULD JUST SAY THAT YOU
KNOW.
THE ONLY OTHER.
PART OF THAT IS THAT WHEN WE DO
HAVE A GREAT ECONOMY AND WE DO
HAVE A VERY INNOVATIVE.
INDUSTRIAL BASE AND AND THAT
INNOVATION IS.
ATTRACTIVE TO.
FOREIGN ACTORS AND AND AND AND
OTHERS AND I'M YOU KNOW WITH
WITH.
AND I THINK THAT WITH WITH THE
CASE OF BOB YOU KNOW SORT OF
POLITICAL STANCES.
LA TIMES WE WILL WILSON
STARTING THE SEA RANSOMWARE AND
OTHER KINDS OF A DENIAL OF
SERVICE ATTACKS. THAT OCCUR.
GENERALLY MOST OF THE STATES ARE
SEEN THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AS
WELL DEPENDS ON ON YOU KNOW WHAT
THE POLITICAL NURSES OF THE OF
AN EVENT THIS MAKE TAKING PLACE
IN THE STATE OR SOME KIND OF A
MESSAGE THAT. A GROUP WANTS TO
MAKE.
BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT
INFRASTRUCTURE WE LOOK AT
STEALING YOU KNOW FROM AN
ESPIONAGE STANDPOINT OR.
OF POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE THOSE THE
ONES THAT WERE REALLY. REALLY
WATCHING OUT FOR BECAUSE.
THOSE TO CREATE A LOT OF DAMAGE
AND AND I'M AS YOU YOU HEARD IN
THE MEDIA OTHERS. THERE IS A LOT
OF.
THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT
THAT IN IN THE COUNTRY TODAY.
CAN YOU ALSO DISCLOSED TO THE
PUBLIC
ON DE AMOUNT OF US CYBER ATTACKS
OUR. OUR. BY CATEGORIES OR
EXAMPLE ATTACK SO BY NATION STAY
ATTACKS BY.
ACTIVISM OR OTHERWISE OR ANY
OTHER INDIVIDUALS ARE.
AND THE LIKE.
I'M ACTUALLY GONNA LOOK WHEN THE
SECOND PANEL COMES UP AND THEY
TALK A BIT MORE ABOUT THAT THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS THAT THEY THAT
THEY CAN BE ABLE TO PROVIDE YOU
LOW BUT HAVE A GREAT THANK YOU.
I I HAVE.
.
A FEW QUESTIONS FOR EACH OF YOU
BUT I I'VE FIRST.
THE GUESTS FIVE ONE IT SAID IN
ISRAEL'S DO YOU HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AND WELCOME TO HAVE.
THE PANEL.
THANK YOU KNOW I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS MADAM
CHAIR.
THE FIRST THAT THE FIRST THING
I.
JUST WANTED TO MENTION.
IN RESPONSE MISTER OBERNOLTE
AYE I WAS.
.
A ABOUT. WHEN WE LOOK AT METRICS
AND AND.
HOW MUCH WE'RE IMPROVING OUR
STANCE I'D I'D THOUGHT WHAT WAS
REALLY QUITE COMPELLING? IS THAT
MOST OF THE DEPARTMENTS WHEN
THEY SWITCHED OFFICE THREE SIXTY
FIVE THAT YOU'RE READY SEEING. A
VERY LARGE DROP IN.
THE NUMBER OF SUCCESSFUL
FISHING EMAILS AND MAYBE YOU CAN
JUST.
MEAN TO YOU KNOW WE ALL WERE
OFTEN TALKING ABOUT ALL THIS
COMPLICATED.
.
TECHNOLOGY BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT I ALWAYS TALK ABOUT IS IT'S
REALLY THE THE THE WEAK LINK IS
ALL. IT'S THE USER SO MAYBE YOU
COULD JUST KIND OF.
TOUCH ON.
THE IMPROVEMENTS YOU'VE SEEN
THAT AS YOU'RE SWITCHING OVER
TO.
OFFICE THREE SIXTY FIVE.
ABSOLUTELY AND DATA ALSO THE A
SECOND PANEL THAT. SHOULD BE W.
CHRIS CHRIS WERE FURTHER
ELABORATE ON THIS AS WELL.
BUT I KNOW IN A BRIEF SUMMARY.
BY SWITCHING THE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AS A PUBLIC SECTOR
EMAIL BOX INTO A SINGLE.
EMAIL SYSTEM CALL A MICROSOFT
OFFICE THREE SIXTY FIVE WERE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT SECURITY
MEASURE HOLISTICALLY. VERSUS IN
THE PAST WHEN EACH DEPARTMENT
ARE HANDLING THINGS ON THEIR OWN
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO DEPEND ON
THAT. INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENTS
IMPLEMENTATION EFFECTIVENESS TO
TO TO TO TO CENTRALLY MANAGING
THE SECURITY MEASURE.
AND.
MICROSOFT ITSELF HAVE ALSO
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN BE
UTILIZED TO HELP SCREEN OUR FLAG
ABOUT MAYBE A BETTER WORK THAT
THESE FISHING THE MOUSE WITH A
COMBINATION OF USER TRAINING. AS
WELL AS TECHNOLOGY ARE BEING
CENTRALLY MANAGE THEN IT'S A
IT'S A MORE CONSISTENT APPROACH
ACROSS THE STATE IN IN MEETING
ABOUT.
MITIGATING OR REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF FISHING AMOUNT THAT
COME TO THE END USER WHICH PUTS
FURTHER BURDEN ON AND YOU SORT
OF SELF TO TRYING TO. YOU KNOW
TO FILTER THOSE SOUTH SO YES THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OFFICE THREE
SIXTY FIVE IS A GREAT EXAMPLE.
OKAY.
BUT I THE QUESTION FOR.
DIRECTOR GILLER DUCE YOU'VE HAD
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF.
EMERGENCIES NATURAL DISASTERS
IN THE LAST YEAR WE'VE SEEN
AROUND THE STATE A LOT SO HOW
HOW IS I'M CYBERSECURITY.
PRIORITIZE WITH WHEN WHEN YOU
HAVE ALL THESE OTHER.
DISASTROUS GOING ON SO WHAT
MIGHT. HAPPEN FOR EXAMPLE IF.
THROUGHOUT FIGHTING THE FIRES
AND THERE IS A.
BIG CYBER ATTACK.
WHAT'S THE ODDS AGREE QUESTION.
IT HAS BEEN QUITE A YEAR AND.
.
AND.
PERSONALLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORT IN YOUR DISTRICT ON ON
THE DISASTERS THAT ARE WE GOING
ON DOWN THERE.
IT YOU KNOW THE THE CAL SECOND
THE TEAM THAT'S THAT'S HERE THIS
IS A DEDICATED TEAM TO
CYBERSECURITY.
PROTECTION AYE IRREGARDLESS OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE STATE
THAT THAT CYBERSECURITY
IMMIGRATION CENTER OUR AND OUR.
THE C. TEASE THAT NETWORK
DEFENSE THAT THERE THE GUARDS
NEVER DEFENSE AND SAGE BE. ALL
OF THEM ARE FOCUSED ON IDEALLY
WITH.
THE DAILY DAY MONITORING OF OF
CYBER THREATS TO THE STATE NOW I
WILL TELL YOU THAT WHEN WE HAVE
A DISASTER.
ALL OF ANY SORT WHETHER IT'S
NATURAL OR OUR HUMAN COST.
THAT THAT INTEGRATION A SORT OF
TAKES A STEP UP WHERE WORK WERE
WERE WORKING MUCH CLOSER WITH
ALL OF OUR PARTNER AGENCIES.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT TIME WE
CAN BE PERCEIVED AS VULNERABLE
DURING THESE
SITUATIONS AND AS A RESULT. OF
SOME OF THESE ACTORS MAY WANT TO
TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO.
CERTAIN KINDS OF.
BY THE VARIOUS ACTIVITY AND SO
WE ARE WE ARE REALLY WORKING
HARD DURING THOSE TIMES THIS
TEAM IS WORKING EXTRA HARD. TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE THE INTERDICT
ANY POTENTIAL PROBLEMS AND LET
ME GIVE AN EXAMPLE THAT.
WE KNOW WE HAD A CASE SINCE IN
CINEMA COUNTY THAT WHILE THEY
WERE DEALING WITH.
FLOOD EMERGENCY.
.
LAST YEAR THERE WAS A DEAD
ALISTAIR ATTACK RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THEIR A RESPONSE WHICH
THEN BROUGHT THEIR SYSTEM DOWN
WHICH MADE IT VERY COMPLICATED
ON THEIR. ABILITY TO DO ALL THE
COORDINATION WITH THE IDEA WE.
THE CYBER SECURITY TO GRACIOUS
CENTER WORKING.
AND CONNECTING THEM WITH THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER. OF.
COMMUNICATED RAPIDLY.
WE WORK WITH OUR OUR NATIONAL
GUARD AND AND.
AND OTHER ENTITIES TO MOVE IN UP
PORTABLE MOBILE CAPABILITIES TO
GET CINEMA COUNTY UP ONLINE TO
BE ABLE TO DO A WORKAROUND TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS. THEIR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE RESPONSIBILITIES WHILE
THEY WERE DEALING WITH THE CYBER
PROBLEM THEY WERE HAVING
THE SITE.
SO I GUESS THE SHORT OF IT IS
THAT WE'RE CONSTANTLY MONITORING
IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
BUT AT TIMES WE ARE ARE LOOKING
AT ANY POTENTIAL PROBLEMS AND
WE'RE PREPARED TO RESPOND.
DURING THOSE EVENTS TO MAKE
SURE WE MITIGATE ANY POTENTIAL
CYBER ATTACK.
CAN AND ON THAT VEIN THAT ARE
YOU STILL ON TRACK FOR TO.
DEVELOP THE UMPS CYBER.
RESPONSE PLAN.
YES ACTUALLY.
AND THAT'S EVER TO GET TALKED
ABOUT IT A LITTLE BIT THAT YEAH
THE THE CYBER RESPONSE PLAN I
THINK.
.
THERE'S A THERE'S A CYBER JOINT
CYBER INCIDENT RESPONSE GUY THAT
WAS THIS PUBLISHED THIS MONTH
AND.
THE WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY NOW TIED IN WITH THE
AS AS A DIRECTOR TOM MENTIONED.
THE PROPER TECHNOLOGY CERDIC
SECURITY OPERATIONS CENTER
BUILDING THAT OUT A CRITICAL
COMPONENT INTO OUR STATE'S
ABILITY TO HAVE THAT FEED IT'S
COMING IN FROM THE DATA CENTER.
INTO THE CAL SEC SO THAT WE NOW
HAVE THIS OVER ARCHING.
SORT OF VISUAL THIS I GUESS YOU
COULD SAY OF OF THE VERY
STREAMS.
THAT PLUGS INTO THE FILE THAT'S
REALLY THE FINAL PIECE TO
PLUGGING INTO WHAT WE CALL OUR
E. SF EIGHTEEN.
RESPONSE GUIDE AND.
AND AND WE WE EXPECT THAT TO BE
DONE HERE WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF MONTHS
RIGHT THANK YOU AND DIRECTOR
TALKING YOU DISCUSSED CBT IS
ROLE AS.
REVIEWER OF.
I. T. REQUESTS HAS BEEN USED TO
INCREASE THE STATE SAYS CYBER.
POSITIONING.
.
I OF PURSUE MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHEN YOU'RE REFERRING TO WHEN
THERE'S A BUDGET CHANGE REQUEST
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL COMING
ALONG HOW DOES. WHAT IS THE
CITY'S ROLE IN REVIEWING AND
RECOMMENDING?
YOU KNOW APPROPRIATE ACTION
NEED TO TAKE ON THOSE BCP.
YES I WE HAVE BEEN IN CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU KNOW THROUGH THAT UP
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL PROCESS.
AND REVIEWING DIED WE WERE ABLE
TO USE INFORMATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF SELF OF BECAUSE
YOU'RE BROUGHT ANNUALLY STILL
HAVE TO SUBMIT THEIRANNUAL SELF
ASSESSMENT REPORT. WERE ABLE TO
USE THAT INFORMATION PLUS THE BI
ANNUAL INDEPENDENT SECURITY
ASSESSMENT ARE CONDUCTED BY
DEPARTMENT OF MY MILITARY OR ANY
THIRD PARTY. IF THEY CHOOSE TO
AS WELL AS THE OUR TRIANNUAL
SOON TO BECOME A EVERY FOUR
YEARS AUDIT OF THE HIGH RISK
DEPARTMENTS. SO.
AND THERE ARE ONGOING SOME
SOMEONE QUARTERLY BASIS SOME ON
IN OTHER FREQUENCY WHAT WE CALL
THAT. A POEM THE.
ACTION FOR MILESTONE.
AS A HOLISTIC OF SCORING PROCESS
IF YOU WOULD ON THEIR SICK.
MAJORITY METRICS AND HOW THE
DEPARTMENTS
THEIR STRATEGY THEIR PLAN THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION TRACK RECORD IN
IN IN MATURING THEMSELVES.
ENOUGH COMPARING THAT TO THE
BUDGET CHANGE REQUEST THAT THEY
HAVE PUT TO CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT
THEY HAVE TO SEE IF THERE ARE
PUTTING THE REQUESTED IN THE
RIGHT PLACE IN MITIGATING THE
RIGHT PHONE ABILITY. SO THAT
KIND OF A REVIEW PROCESS IS
TAKING PLACE BEHIND THE SCENES
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WE
ALSO.
VERY TRANSPARENT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IF WE THINK HEY YOU
HAVE MERIT ON THIS BUT YOU'RE
NOT. REALLY INVESTING IN THE
RIGHT PLACE WERE ALSO WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT SO THEY KNOW HOW
TO MAKE APPROPRIATE ADJUSTMENT.
SO THAT'S OUR.
INVOLVEMENT AND SO THAT'S BEEN
A.
BIG POSITIVE CHANGE DO YOU HAVE
ALL THE TOOLS YOU NEED TO
CONTINUE ON THIS TRAJECTORY.
CORRECT AND AND THANKS TO
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIX SEVENTY LAST YEAR BECAUSE
PRIOR TO THIS WE WERE HEAVILY
RELYING ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
DOING SELF REPORTING YOU KNOW
IT'S A GOOD MEASURE BUT IT WOULD
BE GOOD TO HAVE AN ALSO A CHECK
AND BALANCE YOU KNOW.
ASSESSMENT ON TOP OF DIED SO THE
COMBINATION OF SELF REPORTING
INDEPENDENT ASSESSMENT AND AUDIT
FOR THE HIGH RISK THAT GIVES A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE.
GENERAL BALDWIN DO.
OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE BEEN KEY AND
AND.
GETTING US WHERE WE ARE WITH
THE ASSESSMENTS MILITARY
DEPARTMENT DO YOU THINK THERE IS
A LONG TERM ROLE FOR THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT AND
CYBERSECURITY FROM STATE. THAT
THERE IS.
AND AND THE MAIN REASON FOR
THAT IS THAT.
OUR OWN SOLDIERS AND AIRMEN ARE
TRAINED TO A MUCH HIGHER
STANDARD THAN.
WHAT YOU CAN GENERALLY FIND IN
EVEN THE CIVILIAN WORLD?
ABOUT COMING OUT OF THE OUT OF
THE.
.
SILICON VALLEY NOW BECAUSE OUR
SOLDIERS AND AIRMEN.
GET TRAINED TO THE NSA AND U.
S. CYBER COMMAND STANDARDS.
FOR THAT IT ENABLE THEM TO DO
THEIR WAR FIGHTING CYBER TASKS
OF DEFENDING THE NET NETWORK
ANOTHER OTHER TASKS THAT THEY
GET A SIGN WHEN THEY DO THAT.
WARFIGHTING MISSION.
NAM SO WERE ABLE TO BRING OF
SKILL SETS BACK UP TO A ADVANCED
DEGREE TO BE ABLE TO.
DO ASSESSMENTS AND THEN BE ABLE
TO.
.
COACH DEPARTMENTS AND DEPARTMENT
OF CIO'S ON THINGS THAT THEY CAN
DO TO IMPROVE THEIR CYBER
HYGIENE.
WE'RE FINDING.
ACROSS THE.
ACROSS THE ENTERPRISE
THROUGHOUT STATE GOVERNMENT
THAT.
PEOPLE CYBER WHERE IT SAYS
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS LARGELY BECAUSE
THE EFFORTS OF THE AGENCIES THAT
ARE HERE INVOLVED DIDN'T HURT TO
HAVE A AT. GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER TO TELL TO TUNE INTO IT
TOO.
.
BUT HOME WANTED AND JUST ONE OF
THE IS IS THIS IS KIND OF
SUBJECTIVE BUT BUT YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT.
ABOUT METRICS IS THAT WE NOW
ARE OUR TEAMS ARE MUCH BETTER
RECEIVED WHEN THEY GO INTO.
VISIT DEPARTMENTS AND WE'RE
FINDING A LOT OF DEPARTMENTS
THAT WE GO BACK FOR A SECOND
LOOK.
WHERE IS WHEN WE IN AND THE
FIRST TIME WE FOUND ALL KINDS OF
ALL ABILITIES NOW THEY'VE REALLY
TIGHTENED UP THEIR NETWORKS TO
TIGHTEN UP THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES? AND WE'RE AT THE
POINT WHERE WE CAN DO MORE
ADVANCED
PENETRATION TESTING.
WHEREAS WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
THIS A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. IT
WAS ANYMORE SPEND THE TIME DOING
THAT BECAUSE THERE WERE JUST
ONLY BASIC VULNERABILITIES
ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT SO WE'RE
SEEING A.
THEY.
BUT.
VERY POSITIVE MOVEMENT AND
DIRECTION IN TERMS OF.
LEADERSHIP'S APPROACH NON CYBER
LEADERS UNDERSTANDING THE
THREATS AND UNDERSTAND THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE THEIR
NETWORKS OF THEIR DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES SECURE.
RIGHT INTO GENERAL BALDWIN AND
THEN OF MY LAST QUESTION.
FOR A COMMISSIONER STANLEY IS.
DO GET REQUESTS FOR FROM LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND TO HELP
WITH.
CYBER RELATED CRIME. YES WE DO
CRAM. ART TO NEED A. COMPUTER
CRASH INVESTIGATION UNIT. THEY
WILL ALSO ASSIST LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IF.
IF THERE'S A NEED THERE AND
WILL WORK WITH THIS GROUP TO
GIVE THEM ASSISTANCE AND. ALSO.
INTERNALLY WHEN WHEN WE HAVE
SOMEONE TURN TRYING TO GET IN
OUR SYSTEM OR WE GET FISHING
EMAILS THEY WILL ALSO HELP OUT
THERE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE TWO MORE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT HAVE
JOINED US ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER I CARILLO
AND TO EITHER IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR THIS PANEL.
ANY COMMENTS OR.
ISRAEL HAS PUT I DO HAVE A
QUESTION.
GIVEN THE SKILLS GAP OF THEIR
EXISTENCE SECURITY. DO YOU VIEW
THE ABILITY TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN.
TALENT AND EXPERTISE AS A
PRIORITY.
ABSOLUTELY.
ALL JUST JUMP IN AND FIVE YET
FEW OFF TOWARD A FAIR FREE TO.
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CONTACTS OF.
WE WE THEIR SOUGHT OUT SEVERAL
EFFORTS IN PLACE RIGHT NOW AS I
MENTIONED A WORK FIRST
DEVELOPMENT IS A HUGE PRIORITY.
FORTY MINISTRATION AND UNDER
LEAVE IT OUR SHIP OF OUR GOD
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS EIGHT.
AGENCY.
AND IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE.
AGENCY RECENTLY THERE WAS A.
FIRST TIME IT APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM
THAT WAS DEVELOPED.
END UP WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS WELL AS ON
THE TECHNOLOGY SPECIALIST TO
FIRST TRAIN FOLKS TO ARE
CURRENTLY WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE LECTURE DO A
CAREER CHANGE BUT WE'RE STARTING
THEM WITH YOU KNOW. A A BASIC
BUT BE SENSUAL SCHOOL SET IN
ORDER THE COMING IN DEALING WITH
ACKNOWLEDGING GENERAL WHICH
BECOMES THE BASIS FOR
CYBERSECURITY MEASUREMENT.
THAT'S FONG ONE LEVEL ON THE
OTHER SIDE FOR FOLKS TO ARE
READY IN AND TECHNOLOGY
SPECIALIST AS WELL AS
CYBERSECURITY SPECIALIST WOULD
PROVIDE I'M AN ADDITIONAL.
LEADERSHIP TRAINING AND YOU
WILL HEAR FROM OUR.
AYE CHIEF INFORMATION SECURITY
OFFICER PETER LIEBER THAT WE'RE
ABOUT TO LAUNCH OUR FIRST EVER
INFORMATION SECURITY LEADERSHIP
ACADEMY. AS PROVIDING MORE OF
VANCE TYPE OF A COHORT OF PORCH
TO TRAIN AND RETAIN AND MOTIVATE
YOU KNOW THE HIGHER LEVEL SKILLS
SAID A TECHNOLOGIST. OR
CYBERSECURITY SPECIALISTS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE THIRD
COMPONENT WHICH I'M I'M
PERSONALLY A VERY VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT A ONE BEING A
WOMAN IN TECHNOLOGY.
SECOND I'D ALWAYS WANT TO
DEVELOP THAT EDUCATION.
PIPELINE รณ WORKFORCE PIPELINE
IS TO WORK WITH LOCAL.
HIGH SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES TO
YOU KNOW GET THE INTEREST.
YOU KNOW STAR FROM EARLY AND.
WE.
PARTICIPATED.
LAST YEAR AND I. CONTINUE TO
WOULD DO SO THIS YEAR WITHOUT
EYES SAN LUIS OBISPO.
FLOW.
CSU SELEUCID BESPOKE IN DOING
WHAT IS COST SEPARATE CHALLENGE
FOR THE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA COMPETED
AND CON TO A LONG WEEKEND CAMP
STYLE TO FURTHER COMPETE. AND.
AT THE IMP FORM IN RETURN THAT
TERRY WAS THERE AND ALL OF A
PARTNER WITH THEIR. IF YOU JUST
LOOK AT THE EXCITEMENT AND DIED
I CALL IT YOU KNOW WITH ALL THE
GEEKY FACE AND HOW WE CAN DO
THIS WE CAN DO THAT. YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW ABOUT OUR FUTURE IS
BRIGHT WITH SO MANY FOLKS ARE
INTERESTED IN THAT SO I THINK
IT'S REALLY THE THREE PRONGED
APPROACH. INTO A CONTINUE TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN OUR TOP
TALENT A WORKFORCE ON THE
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY TO HELP
CAREER CHANGE FOR THE FOLKS ARE
INTERESTING DAY BY GIVING THEM
FURTHER EDUCATION. UP AS WELL AS
DEVELOPING A PIPELINE.
GONNA FOR UP AND COMING
WORKFORCE.
HOW MANY COMMUNITY COLLEGES WERE
SELECTED FOR THAT IT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM?
THIS SPECIAL GLAD HE WAS A
PILOT THAT WAS LAUNCHED OF THEM
I THINK IT WAS.
.
IT WAS A COLLEGE OVER IN THE BAY
AREA ALSO WAS THIS ONE SPECIFIC
COLLEGE AS WELL AS A COLLEGE IN
THE SACRAMENTO AREA THAT WAS
PARTNER TOGETHER TO PROVIDE A
TRAIN IN PARTICULAR YEAH TIERCO
SIERRA COLLEGE SO IS THAT TRUE I
BELIEVED I HAVE SET A PROVIDED
THE CURRICULUM.
BUT AS WE CAN EXPAND THIS PILOT
THERE WILL BE MORE OPPORTUNITIES
WONDERFUL I DO WANT YOU TO
CONSIDER CONSIDER SAN BERNADINE
O. COMMUTER COLLEGE PLEASE.
I'M THINKING OUT OF THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO.
YEAH.
AYE I REALLY WANT TO THINK THE
FOUR OF YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND FOR COMING TO AND SPEAK TO
US THIS MORNING WE WE REALLY
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND.
LOVE SEEING THE PROGRESS
SO I'M GONNA CALL UP OUR NEXT
PANEL AND NOW WE'RE GONNA GET A
LITTLE BIT MORE INTO THE WEEDS
AND INTO THE OPERATIONS.
AND.
.
COULD.
THERE WITH THE NEXT GROUP WHO IS
IMPLEMENTING EVERYTHING HAS TO
SAY
.
ALRIGHT WHY DON'T WE.
STAR WITH.
COMMANDER TRASH.
BUT YOUR.
.
SEVEN IRWIN DISTINGUISHED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KEITH
TRASH AND I'M THE COMMANDER OF
THE CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
IMMIGRATION CENTER OR CAL SICK.
BEFORE I REALLY GET STARTED I
WANTED TO SAY THAT I AM.
VERY HONORED TO BE PART OF AND.
TO WORKING WITH
SUCH A GREAT GROUP OF CYBER WAR
YEARS THAT WE HAVE HERE.
I THINK WE'VE REALLY GELLED AS
A GROUP. I THINK WE'VE MADE SOME
REALLY GOOD PROGRESS THAT WE'RE
GONNA TALK ABOUT.
AND I'M REALLY PROUD OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED
OUR HOME AND.
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF WORK TO DO
BUT WE'RE GOING TO KEEP MY
FIGHTING THIS FIGHT AND I'M
REALLY HAPPY TO HAVE THESE FOLKS
IS MAYA BATTLE BUDDIES.
I WON EXPAND UPON.
DIRECTOR GALLUCCI'S COMMENTS
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
CYBERSECURITY IMMIGRATION CENTER
AND HIGHLIGHT THE PROGRESS WE'RE
MAKING AT THE STRATEGIC
TACTICAL.
OPERATIONAL LEVELS AS RETAINS A
CYBERSECURITY RESILIENCY AND
MATURITY.
FIRST LET ME DISCUSS WHAT WE'VE
DONE AT THE STRATEGIC LEVEL.
ITS BEEN A BUSY YEAR AND WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME AND EFFORT
TO MAKE SURE CYBERSECURITY
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE.
FIRST WE CREATED AND PUBLISHED
THE CALIFORNIA JOINT CYBER IT'S
A COMMUNICATIONS FRAMEWORK.
A CLEARLY ARTICULATE THE
COORDINATED PROCESS FOR
COMMUNICATING AND REPORTING
CYBER INCIDENTS.
AND THIS IS FOR ALL STATE LOCAL
TRIBAL TERRITORIAL. AND PRIVATE
SECTOR ORGANIZATIONS ONCE AN
INCIDENT OCCURS.
THIS FRAMEWORK ALSO DISCUSSES
THE ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR EACH OF THE FOUR CORE
PARTNERS.
AS WELL OF THE VICTIM ENTITIES
ONCE AN INCIDENT HAS A S. HAS
BEEN ESCALATED AND IT'S BASED ON
THE CRITERIA THAT WE PUT IN THE
PLAN.
WE ALSO CREATED AND PUBLISHED
THE CALIFORNIA JOINT CYBER
INCIDENT RESPONSE GUIDE. TO
ASSIST ALL CALIFORNIA ANDES BOTH
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC.
TO UNDERSTAND THE IDENTIFICATION
THE REPORTING. AND RECOVERY
PROCEDURES ADOPTED THAT WE'VE
ADOPTED AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
TO ADDRESS THE COURT REQUIREMENT
AND EIGHTY EIGHTEEN FORTY ONE.
THIS IS A STEP BY STEP HOW TO.
MANUAL THAT ANY ENTITY CAN USE
TO DEVELOP THEIR OWN
CYBERSECURITY IT'S A RESPONSE
PLAN OR. USE IT AS A STANDALONE
PLAN SHOULD THEY BECOME VICTIM A
VICTIM OF A CYBER ATTACK.
AND THE CATHOLIC IS ALSO WORKING
TO EXERCISE OUR INCIDENT
RESPONSE CAPABILITIES.
TO THAT END THE CAL SICK.
OUR PARTICIPATED IN THE NORTH
AMERICAN ELECTRIC RELIABILITY
CORPORATIONS GREAT ACTS.
WITH ONE OF OUR UTILITY
PARTNERS.
CRITICS IS A NATIONAL TRAINING
EXERCISE THE TACKLES POTENTIAL
CYBERSECURITY THREATS.
AND VULNERABILITIES IN THE
NATION'S ELECTRIC GRID.
WE ALSO PARTICIPATED IN THE
NATIONAL SIDE REGARD PRELUDE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ACTUAL SIZE
IN MAY OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
NOW SOME REGARD PRELUDE IS
DESIGNED TO ASSIST ORGANIZATIONS
AT ALL LEVELS FROM LOCAL ALL
WOULD FEDERAL.
IN THE DEVELOPMENT AND TESTING
OF CYBER SECURITY PREVENTION
PROTECTION MITIGATION AND
RESPONSE CAPABILITIES.
THIS YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE'RE GONNA AGAIN
PARTICIPATE IN A FEW MONTHS BUT
WE'RE GONNA EXPAND OUR LEVEL OF
PLAY TO INCLUDE EXERCISING OUR
INSTANT RESPONSE PLANS. AND
COORDINATING WITH OUR FOUR CORE
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS.
NOW I'D LIKE TO TAKE OUR TALK A
LITTLE ABOUT THE INITIATIVES
WERE WORKING AT AT THE TACTICAL
LEVEL.
ONEOF THE AREAS WE PLACE A LOT
OF EMPHASIS ON DURING TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WAS ARE OUT
REACH PROGRAM.
IN OTHER WORDS GETTING THE WORD
OUT TO THE COUNTIES CITIES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AS THE
EDUCATIONAL UTILITY. CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE HEALTH CARE AND
BANKING SECTORS
ABOUT WHO THE CAL SICK IS AND
WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP THEM.
AND THIS IS PAID OFF.
WE BEGAN THE YEAR WITH ABOUT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY CYBER THREAT
INFORMATION SHARING PARTNERS AND
A PILOT PROGRAM OF AUTOMATED
CYBER THIEVES WITH THREE OF
THOSE PARTNERS.
TODAY I CAN REPORT TO YOU THAT
WE HAVE OVER FIVE HUNDRED CYBER
THREAT SHARING PARTNERS AND HAVE
MORE THAN DOUBLED OUR AUTOMATED
CYBER THREAT FEED PARTNERS
INCLUDING STATE COUNTY CITY. AND
FUSION CENTER PARTNERS.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH
POTENTIAL PARTNERS RIGHT NOW
INCLUDING A MAJOR PUBLIC
UTILITY.
AND ARE PRESENTLY IN FINAL
COORDINATING TALKS TO GET THEM
ON THE AUTOMATED FEE PROGRAM.
OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE TWENTY
AUTOMATED CYBER THREAT FEED
PARTNERS BY THE END OF CAL YEAR
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS A
DIRECTOR GUILTY DUTY POINTED
OUT.
IN BANKING. AND EDUCATIONAL AND
UTILITIES CREEK ON STRUCTURE AND
THE LIKE.
ANOTHER AREA THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON HARD TO MATURE AND
CAL SICK IS OUR THREAT
INFORMATION SHARING
PARTNERSHIPS.
WE BEGAN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ARMED
WITH ABOUT TWENTY SOURCES OF
CYBER THREAT INFORMATION AND
TODAY WE HAVE OVER SEVENTY
PARTNER ENTITIES PROVIDING
THREAT FEEDS FROM SUCH
ORGANIZATIONS. AS THE FBI.
DEPARTMENT HOMELESS SECURITY
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
AND INDUSTRY EXPERTS SUCH AS FAR
AYE AND THREAT CONNECT.
WE'RE INGESTING THESE FEEDS.
AND SHARING CYBER THREAT
INFORMATION WITH OVER FIVE
HUNDRED CYBER Y. PARTNER
STATEWIDE.
AND THE NUMBER OF PARTNERS IS
CONSISTENTLY GROWING.
THAT MEANS WE CAN PROVIDE A
BROADER RANGE OF CORRELATED
CYBER THREAT INFORMATION TO OUR
STEP STATEWIDE CYBERSECURITY
PARTNERS.
AND ADDITIONALLY I KIND OF GOES
BACK TO A QUESTION EARLIER ABOUT
YOU KNOW OTHER STATES.
WE HAVE HAD CALLS FROM.
A FEW OTHER STATES TO ASK US TO
HELP THEM INITIATE MATURE AND
IMPLEMENT THEIR SABERS A
IMMIGRATION CENTERS IN THEIR
STATES BASED ON WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH MODEL HERE.
NOW I'D LIKE TO TO A DISCUSS
SOME OF THEIR OPERATIONAL
SUCCESSES THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCE
WITHIN THE STATE.
FIRST LET ME.
DISCUSSED THE STATE BAN OUR CUS
PERSKY PRODUCTS.
IN MID JULY OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ARE CASSOCK ANALYSTS
BECAME AWARE OF THREAT
INFORMATION CONCERNING HIS FIRST
YEAR LAB.
WE RESEARCHED A THREAT.
AND IT ASSESSED THE RISK AS A
HIGH PRIORITY.
WE IMMEDIATELY ALERTED DIRECTOR
GIL DIGI.
IN HIS ROLE AS A HOMELAND
SECURITY ADVISER.
TECHNOLOGY.
WITHIN HOURS
WE PREACH SECRETARY BADGER FROM
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS.
AND IN LESS THAN A WEEK THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PUBLISHED A
JOINT POLICY.
DOT OF SHE'S MADE JOINT
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES POLICY
BANNING THE PURCHASE AND USE OF
KASPERSKY LAB PRODUCTS. FROM
STATE MORE NETWORKS AND SYSTEMS
AND WE WERE THE FIRST TO DO SO.
THE CATHOLIC ALSO ISSUED AN
UNCLASSIFIED ALERT TO ALL OF OUR
STATE LOCAL TRIBAL AND PRIVATE
INDUSTRY PARTNERS STATEWIDE.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF INSERT
RESPONSE ASSISTANCE WE PROVIDED.
IT'S TO A TRANSIT AUTHORITY WHO
EXPERIENCED A SIGNIFICANT CYBER
ATTACK.
THE CALCIUM SPOTTED ALONG WITH
OTHER FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
CYBERSECURITY PARTNERS BUT THE
CAL SICK TOOK THE LEAD. AND WE
HELPED COORDINATE THEIR IT'S A
RESPONSE AND HELP THEM GET BACK
UP AND RUNNING TWO HUNDRED
PERCENT.
AND SINCE JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE CASSOCK HAS
COORDINATED THE ANSWER RESPONSE
FOR OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE STATEWIDE INCIDENTS.
INCLUDING CYBER ATTACKS ON
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES
AND PRIVATE SECTOR
ORGANIZATIONS.
THESE INCIDENTS RAGE IN SEVERITY
FROM WEBSITE DEFACE MINTS.
THE MALICIOUS SOFTWARE INCLUDING
BOTNET ACTIVITY.
EMAIL TAX RANSOMWARE COMPROMISED
ACCOUNTS AND STOLEN THAT WERE
CREDENTIALS.
LET ME CLOSE BY SAYING THAT THE
EFFORTS OF THE CAL SICK ARE
TRULY MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO MATURE
IN THE AREA OF CYBER SECURITY
AND WE ARE TAKING A MORE
PROACTIVE APPROACH
A CYBERSECURITY THAN WE EVER
HAVE BEFORE.
WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY. BUT AS
EVERYONE ELSE THAT WE STILL HAVE
WORK TO DO AS WE CONTINUE TO
BUILD OR CYBER RESILIENT
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
APOTHECARY MUCH OUT COMMANDER
TRICIA ARE LET'S TURN TURN OVER
TO NEXT SPEAKER.
LIMIT JUST INTRODUCED US TO THE
REST OF THE PRESENTERS SO. WE
ALSO HAVE CHRIS CRUSOE WHO IS
THE CHIEF A DEPUTY DIRECTOR FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
POPULARLY BURKE A CHIEF
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL. ARE WE ALSO
HAVE LIEUTENANT COLONEL JIM
PARSONS SO WITH THE CYBER
NETWORK DEFENSE TEAM A WITH THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT OF FINALLY
WE HAVE ARE ALSO SCOTT HA HA
HOWLIN. WHO IS THE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER WITH A
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL SO
WITHOUT THAT LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO? OUR.
MR TIP A DIRECTOR A TRUCE.
RIGHT. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON CHRISTOPHER'S
MENTION I'M CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR APARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
APART MY OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES IS A STATE WIDE
DATA CENTER. AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TALK ABOUT WHERE
WE'VE COME IN THE PAST TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS.
PART OF THAT HAS BEEN THE
FUNCTIONAL REALIGNMENT THAT OUT
DIRECTOR TOM SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER
IN HER DISSERTATION TO REALLY
INTEGRATE THE STATEWIDE DATA
CENTER OPERATIONS AND THE OFFICE
OF INFORMATION SECURITY I
CONDUCTED BY OUR AYE. AYE AYE SO
PETER LABOR AND IMPORTANT SIX
NEGATIVE ABOUT IS INTEGRATING
CORE SERVICES ACROSS
PROGRAMMATIC OPERATIONS FOR THE
STATE.
PHASE ONE OF THAT.
PROCESS AND PRIORITY WAS A
STATEWIDE EMAIL MIGRATION OF
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND EMAIL
BOXES IS SLATED TO BE COMPLETE
TOMORROW MARCH FIRST.
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS IS
AGAIN ONE SINGLE STATEWIDE EMAIL
SYSTEM THAT HAS A COMMENT
STATEWIDE POP POSTURE FOR THE
STANDARDIZATION OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLATFORM.
THROUGHOUT THE STATEWIDE NETWORK
IN CALIFORNIA KNOWN TO SEE JEN.
ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT ITEMS OF
THAT NOW IS THAT ONCE WE HAVE
ADVANCED THREAT PROTECTION IN
PLACE IS A COMMON INDICATOR
ACROSS OUR WHOLE EMAIL SYSTEM.
I WOULD BE CLEAR IN TERMS OF
THIS IS A PART OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH PURVIEW THAT WE HAVE
JURISDICTIONAL AUTHORITY FOR
STATUTORY AUTHORITY.
AGAIN THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
COMMON STRUCTURING COMMON
STANDARDS COMMON.
ALSO WANT TO BRING YOUR
ATTENTION AS WELL AS OUR
PROLIFERATION OF OUR CLOUD
ACTIVITIES IN THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF NOW PUBLIC AND COMMERCIAL
CLOUD SERVICES.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOW
PROVIDES TO OUR CUSTOMERS.
WELL NOW WHEN THEY GET THEY HAVE
THEY GET AMAZON OR THEY GET
MICROSOFT AZURE OTHER SERVICES
THAT COME THROUGH OUR TRAIN IT'S
NOW PART OF OUR INTERCONNECTION
CORE INFRASTRUCTURE OF OUR STATE
LIGHT SYSTEM.
WHY IS A SIGNIFICANT AGAIN FOR
SECURITY REASONS WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF SECURITY
STANDARDS IMPOSTERS IN PLACE NOW
THAT ALIGN WITH FEDERAL
STANDARDS AND RECOMMENDATIONS?
VERY SIGNIFICANT PROTECTING
DURING THE STATE'S MOST MISSION
CRITICAL DATA.
AS A BENEFIT OF THAT TO ALSO NOW
WE HAVE IMMIGRATION INTO OUR
PUBLIC PRIVATE PLATFORM WE HAVE
VISIBILITY. AND TO THE STATEWIDE
NETWORKS ARE IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S VERY FEDERATED
STATE WHEN IT COMES TO
TECHNOLOGY THE STANDARDIZATION
OF OUR PLATFORMS
SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE THAT SECURITY A COMMON
SECURITY APPROACH IN A
CENTRALIZED PERSPECTIVE. THAT
ARE STATEWIDE DATA CENTER AND
THEN HOW WE INTEGRATE DOWN INTO
THE DISTRIBUTION OF THOSE
NETWORKS
AND NOW OUR AYE SO PETER LEGAL
TALK MORE ABOUT THAT IN TERMS IN
POINTING. ENCRYPTION IN SOME THE
NEXT STEPS IN THOSE PROVERBIAL
PROCESSES.
THE OTHER AREA TO THE PROVINCE
YOUR ATTENTION SHE GEN ARE
CALIFORNIA GENERAL ENTERPRISE
NETWORK GOVERNMENT IMPRESS
NETWORK NOW WE NOW HAVE A
STATEWIDE OFFICE OF
SECURITY CENTER THAT OPERATIONS
INTRO ROUNDS THAT TERRORISTS IN
TERMS OF MOVING FORWARD. SO THE
SE WHY DATACENTER TODAY
EFFECTIVE ON JULY FIRST WE HAVE
MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY AND
OTHER FOLKS RUNNING OUR TWENTY
FOUR BY SEVEN SECURITY
OPERATIONS CENTER SIGNIFICANT
MONITORING AND MANAGING AND PORT
SCANNING OF OUR NETWORK.
SO HAVING THIS INTEGRATION TOUCH
POINTS ALLOW WITH CLOUD SERVICES
NOW THAT'LL. BASICALLY TERRAIN
TO OUR FIRE ONE NETWORK. PUTS US
IN A BETTER PLACE FROM A
SECURITY POSTURE HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALSO ASIDE FROM THAT TO THE
INTEGRATION OF US COMPONENTS IS
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE NOW WE
HAVE DATA INTEGRATION COMPONENTS
WITH CAL SICK IN OUR PARTNERSHIP
HERE AND WERE BEGINNING TO DO
THE NECESSARY OUR RICH WAS CITY
AND COUNTY REPRESENTATION. ON
HOW WE CAN LOOK AT A COMMON
STATEWIDE IT PLATFORM FOR
SECURITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE OUT OF THE
PAST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS WE'VE
COME A LONG WAY IN TERMS OF
STANDARDIZING BILL TECHNOLOGY
FROM A PLATFORM. FROM A CLOUD
PERSPECTIVE AND ALLOWING
NECESSARY FOLKS IN WHO CARRY THE
HIGHEST DEGREES OF SECURITY
CONTRACTIONS TO BE ABLE TO
PREVENT. ANY TYPES OF MISSION
CRITICAL ISSUES FROM HAPPENING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
STOPPING THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
OPERATIONS WE TAKE THAT VERY
IMPORTANT WE TAKE IMPORTANT IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE DO
STRATEGICALLY AND ALSO
TACTICALLY AS WE DEVELOP OUR
PLAN.
AS MENTIONED INFORMATION
SECURITY IS OF THE SECOND
QUADRANT AND OUR TWENTY TWENTY
VISION AND DIRECTOR TOM AND I
CONTINUE TO PROMOTE. INFORMATION
SECURITY IS A CORE COMPONENT OF
DIGITAL SERVICES AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT COMPETENCY
CAPABILITIES AND PROMOTION.
SO ALL IN ALL THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF HAVING A SOLID FUNDAMENTAL
OPERATIONS PLAN IS KEY TO OUR
SUCCESS MOVING FORWARD AND WE
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THAT
FOUNDATION. AS WE AFFECT THE
RIGHT CHANGES HERE FOR OUR
CITIZENS ON THE CUSTOMER'S GROUP
CHAPTER CALIFORNIA.
I'M GOING TO TURN THIS OVER NOW
TO PETER LEAVE IT REALLY TO TALK
ABOUT THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES WHAT WE'VE DONE WITH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND HOW
ARE NOT ACTING IN THIS IS
SEARCHING WITHIN LEGISLATION
THAT'S BEEN SPONSOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MISTER LABOR.
I DO.
GOOD MORNING.
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE HERE.
I'M EXCITED TO TALK ABOUT A LOT
OF THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE AND.
AND ANSWER ALL YOUR QUESTIONS.
AS YOU KNOW THERE TWO ARMS OF
THE OFFICE INFORMATION SECURITY
WHICH I WE'D WHICH FALLS UNDER.
DIRECTOR TOM.
IN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY.
WE HAVE AN OPERATIONAL
COMPONENT AND WE HAVE A POLICY
IN OVERSIGHT COMPONENT AND I'LL
START OFF WITH THE OPERATIONAL
COMPONENT. AS IS MOST GERMANE TO
THE TOPICS TODAY.
WE'VE TALKED A BIT ABOUT THE
CDT SECURITY OPERATIONS CENTER
THE CT SOCK.
I JUST I THINK ONE OF THE BIG
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WE'VE MADE IS
THIS TIME THIS LAST YEAR.
IT WAS JUST A CONCEPT.
A.
WITHIN A YEAR WE'VE ACTUALLY AT
WITH AND ACTUALLY FIVE MONTHS WE
WILL STAND UP OUR FIRST
CAPABILITY WITH IT.
AND TODAY.
WE'VE SEEN THAT IT'S NOW TWENTY
FOUR BY SEVEN. IT'S CO STAFFED
WITH BOTH THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS CIVILIAN
SERVICE.
I AND IT'S EFFECTIVE WERE ON
AVERAGE.
IT FLUCTUATES OR BLOCKING
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ATTACKS.
MALICIOUS PROBES.
PER DAY.
WE ASK US FAR HAVE REVIEWED.
APPROX ME HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND.
SUSPICIOUS OFFENSE OR ALERTS.
AND WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT IF
A. INDICATION OF A TYPE OF.
ATTACK OR TRAFFIC WHICH MAY BE.
INDICATOR OF IT AN ATTACK.
OUR FOLKS WILL ACTUALLY GO IN
AND DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT IT
IS SO THE INVESTIGATE. SO
SIGNIFICANT WORK EFFORT.
AND IT'S.
IT'S IT'S A PRETTY GOOD A STACK
THE SHOW THAT WERE ACTUALLY
SHOWING PROGRESS.
BUT IS IT EFFECTIVE I WOULD SAY
YES SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN JULY.
WE'VE ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED. AND
HELPED.
ENTITIES REMEDIATE EIGHTEEN
DISTINCT MALICIOUS.
ACTIONS OR EVENTS.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT MAY HAVE
SLIPPED THROUGH THE CRACKS
PREVIOUSLY.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
SOCK INTO IS DESIGNED TO DO. IS
TO HELP A STATEWIDE.
DETECTION AND MONITORING
CAPABILITY.
INTO POWER.
DEPARTMENTS AND ENTITIES.
TO KNOW MONITORING NETWORKS AND
ENSURE THAT THEY DON'T MISS
ANYTHING. UNABLE TO REMEDIATE.
YA MALICIOUS OFFENSE ASSUMES
THAT CAR.
ANOTHER KEY COMPONENT OF THE
SOCK IS WERE ACTUALLY STRATEGIC
PARTNER WITH CAL SICK.
AND WERE VERY EXCITED WITH THIS
WE CAN JUST.
INTELLIGENCE PROVIDED FROM CAL
SICK WHICH IS A THREAT
INTELLIGENCE FEED.
IT'S COMBINED FEED AND STATE
SPECIFIC.
A DIRECTOR VERDUCCI HAD
MENTIONED THERE ARE VERY FEW.
STATES OUT THERE THAT CAN DO
THIS I WOULD SAY. A VERY FEW IS
A UNDERSTATEMENT.
YEAH.
AT DOT GOV SPECIFIC FEED.
ALLOWS OUR INTELLIGENCE.
OR ALLOWS OUR ANALYSTS TO
UTILIZE CUSTOMIZED INTELLIGENCE
TO MAKE THEIR JOB A LOT EASIER.
BY BEING A STRATEGIC PARTNER
WITH CAL SICK.
WE IMMEDIATELY PROVIDE A ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY ENTITIES AT
THE NETWORK LEVEL.
NOW BEING ABLE TO PASS ALERTS
AND INFORMATION OVER TO CAL
SICK.
AND THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT. AND
OUR ABILITY AS A STATE TO
DETECT.
MONITOR UMPIRE NETWORK TRAFFIC.
ANOTHER ARE A KEY COMPONENT OF
THIS.
.
IS REALLY DISTRESSING THAT.
UP THERE A COUPLE FACTORS THAT.
.
I WOULD MAKE SURE YOU'RE AWARE
OF ONE. THIS IS A.
MARATHON NOT A SPRINT SPECIAL
INCOMES NETWORK DETECTION.
AND OUR CAPABILITY THERE.
OUR FOLKS ARE NEW.
THEY STOOD UP IN JULY AYE BUT
WE'VE INVEST A LOT OF TIME AND
EFFORT AND THEY'VE BEEN
EXTREMELY CAPABLE THEIR JOBS AS
FAR. AND AS SOMETHING THAT.
WILL BE CONTINUALLY ITERATING
ON.
MOVING FORWARD INCREASING WITH
ADDITIONAL CAPABILITY.
ADDITIONAL TRAINING.
YOU KNOW AND AND AND ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AS WE SEE OTHER NEED
TO DO SO.
SO I HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS THERE
ON ON THAT FRONT FOR SURE.
SPEAKING TO OF THE POLICY AND
OVERSIGHT A COMPONENT OF MY
OFFICE.
I WANT TO TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THAT
AS WELL.
WE HAVE.
.
EXPERIENCED A LOT OF GROWTH
AGAIN IN THIS AREA AND
IMPROVEMENT.
FIRST ON THE POLICY SIDE.
WE'VE LEVERAGED.
THERE'S SOME REALLY GREAT STUFF
COMING FROM OF THE LEGISLATURE.
US SUCH AS AB EIGHTEEN FORTY ONE
MAYBE TEN TWENTY. TO HELP
IMPROVE OUR.
TECHNOLOGY RECOVERY PLANS THIS
IS THE PLAN THAT ALL ENTITIES IN
THE STATE ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE.
.
DETAILS WHAT THEY DO IF
SOMETHING GOES WRONG THERE'S A
DISRUPTION OR AN EVENT THAT IT
KNOCKS OUT THERE ARE CRITICAL
SYSTEMS.
HOW DO THEY BRING US BACK
ONLINE?
THOSE TO.
BILLS ACTUALLY STRENGTHEN IT BY.
IT MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CRITICAL SYSTEMS NOW.
SPECIFICALLY DETAILED INTO THOSE
REPORTS AND THEY HAVE.
PLANS ON HOW TO REMEDIATE IN
CASE THERE IS AN ISSUE THAT
OCCURS WITH THEM.
IT'S A IT'S A BIG IMPROVEMENT.
ALSO AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY THREE
A DIRECTOR TOM MENTIONED THIS
PREVIOUSLY.
IT SECURITY SPENDING THIS IS
THAT WE PUT OUT A POLICY ON THIS
AS WELL REALLY LOOKING FORWARD
STARTED GETTING DATA.
THIS NEXT YEAR ON THIS.
THIS WILL ALLOW FOR US TO SEE
HOW THE SECURITY SPENDING IS.
GOING WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
DEPARTMENTS ENTITIES ARE ABLE
THEN MATCH THAT UP WITH THEIR
OVERALL EFFECTIVENESS
MEASUREMENTS.
AND TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF.
BUT THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE USING
UTILIZING THEIR.
FUNDS WISELY.
AND HELPING THEM OUT IN
PRIORITIZING IF IF AT ALL
POSSIBLE.
WE HAVE ALSO DRAMATICALLY
EXPANDED OUR WORKFORCE AND
TRAINING COMPONENT.
OF MY OFFICE.
SOME STATISTICS HERE WE'VE GONE
FROM A APPROX WE TEACHING FIFTY
SEVEN STUDENTS A YEAR AYE IN IT
WHICH OR THE INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICERS. AND THEIR
SECURITY STAFF TO THIS LAST
FISCAL YEAR OF THUS FAR IF.
TAUGHT A HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
THOMAS THE THREEFOLD INCREASE
MORE ACTION GOING THROUGH THAT
EVEN FURTHER THIS YEAR.
WE ALSO HELP FIFTEEN COMMUNITY
WORKSHOPS.
SINCE I'VE BEEN AT THE HELM.
WITH ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED
PARTICIPANTS.
SPANNING ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE A DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND ENTITIES.
OF THESE WORKSHOPS ARE DESIGNED
TO HELP IMPROVE OUR POLICY AHEAD
GET A COMMUNITY FEEDBACK ON
WHAT'S WORKING WHAT DOES NOT
WORK.
I AND WE'VE MADE DOZENS OF
POLICY CORRECTIONS BASED OFF OF
THEIR INPUT WHICH HAS BEEN
FANTASTIC.
.
AS DIRECTOR TRONG ALSO MENTIONED
WERE PILED TEEN.
.
US HE'S GONNA POLICY WE'RE
ACTUALLY OF.
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS YEAR IN
INFORMATION SECURE TO LEADERSHIP
ACADEMY.
THIS IS THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
FROM A SECURITY STANDPOINT THIS
IS FOLLOWING THE FOOTSTEPS OF A
SOME GREAT EFFORT ALREADY.
SUCH AS THE I. T. I'M
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY HITLER.
AND THIS WILL BE A.
I BELIEVE FIVE WEEK
OF COURSE.
DESIGNED.
SPECIFICALLY FOR.
INFORMATION SECURITY LEADERS
WITHIN THE STATE.
INCLUDING AYE IF RESCUED
OFFICERS AGENCY INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICERS AND STAFF
LOOKING TO BE CAN FILL THOSE
POSITIONS.
AND COVERS A CRITICAL CORE.
SKILL SET OF.
NOT JUST HARD SECURITY SKILLS
BUT ALSO LEADERSHIP AND.
SOFT SKILLS SUCH AS HOW DO WE.
YOUR AS A DIET SO HOW DO YOU
BROADCAST THE BUSINESS LEADERS.
THAT SECURITY IS IMPORTANT AND
ENSURING THAT YOU HEAR WHAT THEY
HAVE TO SAY INCORPORATING THAT
INTO YOUR STRATEGY.
MOVE AFFORD.
WILL BE CONTINUALLY EXPANDING
OUR WORKFORCE AT ENGAGEMENT
COMPONENTS.
WITH ADDITIONAL WORKSHOPS.
ADDITIONAL TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND WERE VERY EXCITED FOR THAT.
WERE ALSO A LOOKING TO PILOT.
CERTAIN STATEWIDE AYE
CAPABILITIES SUCH AS ANTI
PHISHING TRAINING FOR THE STATE
WE'RE LOOKING HOPEFULLY ROLE AYE
A PALETTE OF THAT OUT THIS NEXT
YEAR.
AND WERE. REALLY EXCITED TO DO
AS WELL.
ON THE OVERSIGHT PORTION.
WE HAVE TO.
WINGS OF THE OVERSIGHT HOW
WOULD YOU OVERSIGHT FOR STATE
ENTITIES WE HAVE A.
ASSESSMENT INDIVIDUAL.
SECURITY OR INDEPENDENT
SECURITY ASSESSMENT OR AN ISA. I
WHICH WE'VE PARTNERED WITH A C.
M. D. AND WE DO ALLOW THIRD
PARTIES.
TO TO I DO THAT AS WELL WITH
THE ENTITIES IF THEY SO DESIRE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A POLICY BASED
ON IT WHICH COMES ON MY OFFICE
WHICH THE OUGHT WORKSHOPS. ARE
SEEN IN THE OUR AUDIT OVERSIGHT
BRANCH.
.
HUGE AMOUNT OF IMPROVEMENT ON
THIS AREA AS WELL I'M HAPPY TO
SAY WE'VE MANAGED TO CUT THEM.
TIME IT TAKES TO DO A POLICY
AUDIT ARE ALMOST IN HALF.
WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS IS.
WE'VE ALSO PUT TOGETHER A
ADVISORY GROUP THAT HELPS A
TRAIN NOW A MENTOR.
ENTITIES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE THE BEST POSSIBLE
INFORMATION SECURE PROGRAMS TO
HAVE.
YEAH OR CABLE BILL MAKING.
WE'VE GONE FROM THE LAST TWO
YEARS WE WE'VE CONDUCTED ABOUT
SIXTEEN.
OR SEVENTEEN AUDITS THINK RUN
TRACK FOR THIS YEAR. A COMBINED.
SORRY THIS NEXT FISCAL YEAR I'M
I'M PLEASE TO SAY WERE AIMING TO
DO FIFTEEN AUDITS AND FIFTEEN
CHECK INS PER FISCAL YEAR. IT'S
ALMOST TRIPLING THE CAPACITY OF
ABOUT REACH TO THE ENTITIES OUT
THERE.
AND IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT OUR TEAM HAS.
HAS LED SOME VERY PLEASE TO
REPORT THAT.
THUS FAR WE FOUND APPROXIMATELY
FOUR OR NOT PROBABLY WE FOUND
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
FINDINGS.
ON THE POLICY SIDE OF HOUSE.
THOSE ARE GAPS IN INFORMATION
SECURITY PROGRAMS THINGS THAT NO
NEED TO IMPROVE CROSS THE STATE.
AND DATA FROM THAT HAS HELPED US
DEVELOP ACTUALLY THE FIRST EVER
A CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
CYBERSECURITY MATURITY METRIC I
WHICH I BELIEVE.
YOU HAD ASKED ABOUT EARLIER.
THIS ALLOWS US TO
QUANTITATIVELY. MEASURE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ENTITIES ARE
AND HOW THEY'RE DOING ON THEIR
PERMISSION SECURITY PROGRAMS AT
AN APPLES TO APPLES. BIGGER.
COMPARISON.
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
WHILE WE'VE DONE A GREAT JOB OF
PUTTING UP WITH THE BASELINE
STANDARD IS.
YOU KNOW FOR CYBERSECURITY AND
REALLY TRYING TO GET FOLKS TO.
BE EMPOWERED TO BUILD THAT OUT
NOW RUSSIA CAN HAVE AN EFFECT
MISS MEASUREMENT THE SAY ON A
SCALE OF ONE FOR.
YOUR DEPARTMENT MISSION BOARD
ETCETERA RATES HERE.
IS WHERE YOU NEED TO BE.
BASED ON SPECIFIC METRICS PULLED
FROM A LOT OF THE OVERSIGHT KEEP
A CAPACITY AND CAPABILITIES VERY
HAVE.
CMT AYE AYE ESSAYS AS WELL AS
OUR OF OUR POLICY OF AUDITS.
.
I WILL NOT TALK ABOUT THE I SAY
PROGRAM I'M RELIEVED MY
COLLEAGUE SIXTEEN COLLEGE TO DO
THAT.
THERE HAVE BEEN IMPROVEMENTS IN
THERE AS WELL IN WORKING WITH
FOR CORD IMPROVING THAT.
THIS LAST YEAR WERE VERY
PLEASED WITH THE RESULTS FROM
THAT.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO.
SUMMARIZING CLOSING.
AGAIN REITERATING.
NOT THIS IS A MARATHON NOT A
SPRINT.
WE ARE WE ARE JUST GETTING
STARTED ON THIS AND AND.
GOING BACK TO.
THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED EARLIER WHAT WORKS
WAS DOES NOT WHAT DOES NOT WORK.
WHAT WORKS IS HAVING?
FORUMS LIKE THIS INCREASED
LEADERSHIP SUPPORT OF THROUGH
DIRECTOR TRONG DIRECTOR GARY
DUTY.
YA SECRETARY BADGERING AND.
YOU KNOW AND NOT GOTTEN THAT
THE GOVERNMENT GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
THAT ALLOWS FOR US TO GET WHERE
WE ARE TODAY WITHOUT THAT WE'VE
NEVER WOULD HAVE MADE.
AND.
WERE EXTREMELY APPRECIATIVE OF
THAT WHAT DOES NOT WORK.
THE STRATEGY WHICH WE'VE HAD OF
THE STATE THUS FAR HAS BEEN.
ISLANDS OF EXCELLENCE.
THAT'S A PROBLEM BECAUSE IT
LEADS TO ISLANDS OF NEGLECT.
WE'RE LOOKING TO NOT BREAK DOWN
THOSE SILOS
AND MOVING FORWARD.
AND.
ONE OF THE KEY THINGS WE'RE
DOING THIS NEXT OF THIS YEAR. IS
PUTTING TOGETHER A OF LONG TERM
STRATEGY WHICH FALLS UNDER THE
VISION TWENTY TWENTY PLAN.
OF WHAT WE WANT TO DO AS A STATE
WHEN IT COMES TO CYBERSECURITY
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET TO AND
STATE WHAT IS AND STATE LOOK AT.
WHERE RIGHT NOW ARE LOOK LIKE
WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS?
FOR OR PARTNERS AND OUR.
THE COMMUNITY TO DEVELOP NEVER
HOPEFULLY ROLLING THAT OUT.
THIS YEAR.
AND.
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO SEE WHERE
WE'RE GOING NOTHING GETS A KEY
COMPONENT SPECIALTY TRY TO
FIGURE OUT. DOESN'T FIT WITHIN
THE BCP ARE THEY ASKING FOR THE
RIGHT THINGS THINGS ALONG THOSE
LINES.
TOGETHER COURSE QUESTIONS JUST
ANSWERING THOSE QUICKLY.
MISSING TOOLS ABSOLUTELY.
BUT WERE AWARE OF IT AND THIS
IS AGAIN ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
WE'RE BUILDING TOWARDS.
BLASPHEMY WANNA DO GOING TO
YOUR OTHER QUESTION WHICHIS ARE
THERE TOOLS WE DO NOT UTILIZE.
IDENTIFYING THE TOOLS
CAPABILITIES WE NEED AND THEN
ITERATIVELY AND AND THOUGHTFULLY
PUTTING TOGETHER STRATEGY OF HOW
WE ROLL THOSE OUT WILL PREVENT
US FROM HAVING TOOLS THEY JUST
SIT ON THE SHELF.
AND THAT'S OUR STRATEGY THUS
FAR SPECIAL THE.
SECURITY OPERATIONS CENTER.
AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD WILL BE
INCREASING CAPABILITY AND
TECHNOLOGY.
TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE.
AND THAT IS ALL I HAVE OF
THAT'LL THINK I I BELIEVE PASS
IT OVER TO.
THE TELFER MILITARY TARGET GIRL
PARSONS TO ED WE THE WAY ON I
SIX THINK THEIR MATCH.
THE GOOD O'DONNELL COLONEL JIM
PARSONS.
THANKS SIR A GOOD MONEY MANAGER
MADAM CHAIR CO CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MAJOR GENERAL NOLAN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK THIS MORNING. I WILL BE
ADDRESSING THE INDEPENDENT
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS AND HOW
THOSE HAVE BEEN GOING OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS.
FOR STARTERS A SHORT OVERVIEW.
AN INDEPENDENT SECURITY
ASSESSMENT IS A VERY TECHNICAL
ASSESSMENT OF AN AGENCIES
SYSTEMS AND NETWORKS. TO
DETERMINE HOW EFFECTIVELY THEY
ARE MANAGING THOSE SYSTEMS AND
THEIR CYBERSECURITY MATURITY. AS
MR LABOR LIKES TO CALL IT.
AND I WOULD AGREE SO.
THINK THE CRITERIA THE CRITERIA
THAT WE USE IN THESE ASSESSMENTS
WE WE PUT A LOT OF EFFORT INTO
DEVELOPING THOSE WITH THE.
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICE
OBVIOUSLY THE CHAU CONTROLS OR
THE CI SO CONTROLS THOSE
CRITERIA WE PUT A LOT OF EFFORT
INTO THE CRITERIA TO MAKE THEM
REPEATABLE AND TO GENERATE
METRICS FOR WHICH WE CAN USE TO.
GAUGE THE CYBERSECURITY
MATURITY IN THE AGENCIES THAT WE
VISITED.
AND AS MR LABOR INDICATED MANY
OF THOSE WILL.
TIE RIGHT INTO HIS CYBERSECURITY
METRICS THAT HE HAS DEVELOPED.
.
SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN THEM
MILITARY APARTMENT FOR THE SIMON
OUR DEFENSE TEAM WE'VE BEEN TO
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ENTITIES.
TWENTY THREE OF THOSE WAR A
NONTRADITIONAL STATE AGENCIES
SUCH AS THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
A C. ISSUE OR ACCOUNTING THOSE
TYPES OF ENTITIES SO WE'VE BEEN
TO A FEW OF THOSE.
WE HAVE COMPLETED OVER A
HUNDRED AYE ESSAYS TODAY AND
SENSE.
.
THE BEGINNING OF FISCAL YEAR
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN WE'VE ANALYZED
AND SCAN AND ABOUT SIXTY
THOUSAND STATE THAT.
SO THAT'S WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
SO OUR PERSPECTIVE AFTER HAVING
DONE THESE ASSESSMENTS.
FROM AN ENTERPRISE LEVEL YOU'VE
HEARD THE FOUR CORE PARTNERS
TALK ABOUT THE CAL SICK AND THE
CDT SOCK AND AN ENTERPRISE LEVEL
THOSE ARE GREAT THEY REALLY
HARDEN THE EXTERIOR THEY
PROTECTED PERIMETER. AND THEY
HAVE VISIBILITY TO THE INSIDE
AND THAT'S CRITICAL.
THAT IS DEFINITELY A COMPONENT
THAT'S REQUIRED FROM AN
ENTERPRISE PERSPECTIVE YOU ALSO
HEARD ABOUT THE OFFICE THREE
SIXTY FIVE MINUTES EMAIL
DEPLOYMENT. AND ALL OF THE MAIL
BOXES THAT GO IN THERE AND THAT
IS AN ENTERPRISE DEPLOYMENT THAT
REACHES EVERY SINGLE USER. SO
EVERY USER'S MAILBOX.
GAINES THE PROTECTIONS FROM THE
OFFICE THREE SIXTY FIVE POLICIES
AND.
SECURITIES CONTROLS ARE IN
PLACE. AND THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE IN THE PAST FEW YEARS
ATTACKERS HAVE DISCOVERED THAT
THEY DON'T NEED TO COMPROMISE
THE MONOLITHIC DATABASE WITH ALL
THE HIGH TECH SECURITY CONTROLS
AND MONITORING. THEY JUST NEED
TO COMPROMISE THE USER.
THE USER HAS ACCESS TO THAT DATA
BECAUSE THE USER USES THAT DATA
EVERYDAY SO THEY COMPROMISE A
STANDARD USER AND THEN THEY GAIN
ACCESS TO ALL THE DATA THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR. SO FROM.
MOST SECURITY PROFESSIONALS
WOULD TELL YOU THAT THE
PERIMETER REALLY HAS SHIFTED
FROM THE OUTSIDE OF THE NETWORK.
TO EACH AND EVERY DESKTOP EACH
AND EVERY USER IS NOW THE
SECURITY FROM.
SO PROTECTING EACH OF THOSE
USERS AS YOU MENTIONED THIS
MORNING MA'AM WE NEED TRAINING
FOR THE USERS BECAUSE THERE
GENERALLY CONSIDERED TO BE THE
WEAKEST LINK.
SO THAT TAKES US TO INDIVIDUAL
AGENCIES AND THE FOCUS OF THE
AYE A SAY AND WHAT HAVE WE SEEN
THEIR.
WE HAVE SEEN SOME INCREASE AND
SENIOR LEADERS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OR IN AGENCIES
FOCUSING ON CYBERSECURITY
THEY'RE MORE AWARE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON AND IT'S A HIGHER
PRIORITY FOR THEM. SO THEY'RE
WILLING TO DEDICATE RESOURCES TO
THINGS LIKE PATCHING WHICH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
EQUIFAX I THINK WOULD TELL YOU
THAT THEY REALLY WISH THEY HAD
PATCH THAT APACHE STRUTS
AFFORDABILITY.
RIGHT THERE ARE MILLIONS OF US
THAT WISH THEY WERE TO PASS
THAT.
SO.
PATCHING IS HARD.
PATCHING SYSTEMS AND ENTERPRISE
IT TAKES.
NOT JUST PEOPLE IT TAKES THE
RIGHT SECURITY PEOPLE TO MANAGE
THOSE SYSTEMS AND TO PATCH ALL
THE COMPUTERS AND ALL THE.
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE PASSED
SUCCESSFULLY SO IT'S A RESOURCE
INTENSIVE PROCESS. AND I THINK
AGENCIES ARE BECOMING AWARE.
ESPECIALLY AFTER WE SCANNED
THEM THAT THEY NEED TO APPLY
RESOURCES TO THOSE TO TO PATCH
THOSE ISSUES AND TO DO THAT
PROCESS.
AGAIN KIND OF IN THE WEEDS.
.
WE'RE FINDING FEWER UNSUPPORTED
OPERATING SYSTEMS.
WINDOWS XP IS FINALLY GOING
AWAY STRAIGHT OUT OF SUPPORT FOR
YEARS AND YEARS AND IT'S FINALLY
LEAVING THE NETWORKS THAT'S
GREAT.
.
WE ALSO HAVE TALKED BEFORE ABOUT
A LOT OUT OF THE BOX
CONFIGURATIONS WHERE AGENCIES
ASSEMBLY.
AND SAW THE OPERATING SYSTEM AND
JUST GO WITH THAT THEY JUST
LEAVE IT AS A KIND OF THE BOX.
AND OPERATING SYSTEMS ARE
GENERALLY CONFIGURED SO THEY
WORK WELL FOR YOU AT HOME
THEY'RE NOT USUALLY CONSIDER
CONFIGURED VERY WELL TO WORK IN
AN ENTERPRISE ENVIRONMENT. SO
WHEN YOU GET A SYSTEM OUT OF THE
OUT OF THE BOX AS IT WERE YOU
NEED TO CONFIGURE IT TO BE
SECURING ENTERPRISE ENVIRONMENT
AND WE'RE FINDING THAT AGENCIES
ARE ARE STARTING TO FOCUS ON.
THAT'S A VERY GOOD FINING.
.
I'M OLD AND MY EYES ARE FAMOUS.
A.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED TO FIND RECENTLY
IS WERE STARTING TO SEE
ADVANCED.
NEXT GENERATION AND A VIRUS ON
THE IN POINTS.
SO ANTI VIRUS TEN YEARS AGO WAS
A SIGNATURE BASED EVENT WHERE.
IT KNEW WHAT MOST OF THE VIRUSES
LOOKED LIKE BASED ON.
THE CONTENTS OF THE FILES AND IT
WOULD JUST LOOK IN THE
SIGNATURES TO SEE IF YOU HAD A
VIRUS.
I THINK THE NUMBER IS THERE ARE
ON THE ORDER OF FIFTEEN THOUSAND
NEW.
VIRUSES OR MALWARE SAMPLES EVERY
COUPLE OF MINUTES.
SO THE SIGNATURE BASED AND IRIS
ISN'T PARTICULARLY EFFECTIVE
ANYMORE.
SO THAT ARE OURS THAT'S CAPABLE
OF
SPOTTING THINGS THAT IT HASN'T
SEEN BEFORE IT'S CAPABLE OF
PREVENTING EXECUTIONS OF. OR
PREVENTING EXECUTION AND NOW
WHERE.
AND ALERTING CENTRALLY SO.
AND DAY AND DAYS PASSED THE
WORKSTATIONS ARE THE SYSTEMS ON
THE NETWORK OR A BLACK HOLE.
WHAT HAPPENED ON THE USER'S
WORKSTATION?
AND TELL WAS REALLY BAD NOBODY
HAD ANY IDEA NO ONE SAW THAT
THAT'S IN STATE GOVERNMENTS AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IT'S IN THE
COMMERCIAL WORLD. IN THE PAST
THAT WAS HUGE PROBLEM.
NOW YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SEE
EACH AND EVERY WORKSTATION.
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE EACH
WORKSTATION IS BECOMING THE
PERIMETER BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THE ATTACKERS ARE ATTACKING SO
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A SYSTEM ON
EACH INDIVIDUAL WORKSTATION.
THAT CAN DETECT THAT ACTIVITY
AND REPORT IT TO A SECURITY
ENGINEER THAT CAN RESPOND TO IT
IN A TIMELY FASHION.
WE'RE STARTING TO SEE THOSE AND
AGENCIES WE WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
SEE AT. AN ENTERPRISE ROLLOUT OF
THAT.
.
TO SEE.
WHERE?
THE CDT THAT THE CD TO SOCK THE
CALTECH THOSE. ENTITIES CAN
ACTUALLY SEE ON WORKSTATIONS
WHAT'S HAPPENED.
.
GO THAT MYSELF BOXER AND.
SO AFTER WE'RE DONE WITH OUR
INDEPENDENT SECURITY SYSTEMS WE
GATHER A LOT OF DATA WE DO ALL
THAT. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
OFFER TO AGENCIES TO TRY AND ADD
VALUE IS WE HAVE A COUPLE IS
SECURITY ENGINEERS THAT ARE
REALLY GOOD AT POLICY BASED.
HARDENING OF SYSTEMS SO THAT WE
WE OFFER TO GO BACK TO THE
AGENCIES AND SIT DOWN WITH THEM
AND TRY AND. WALK THEM DOWN THAT
PATH THAT ALSO A COMPLICATED
PATH TO STROLL DOWN.
SO WE PROVIDE SUPPORT THAT WAY
WE'VE HAD ELEVEN AGENCIES THAT
HAVE TAKEN US UP ON THAT SO WE
DO GO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO SOME
AGENCIES AT THEIR REQUEST.
AFTER WE'VE DONE THE
ASSESSMENTS WITH THEM.
.
AFTER THE ASSESSMENT COMPLETELY
DONE WE'VE STARTED PROVIDING A
SURVEY TO SEE HOW WE'VE. HOW
WE'VE DONE IN THE IN THE
INDEPENDENT SECURITY ASSESSMENT
PROCESS AND WHAT THE AGENCIES
FEEDBACK WAS?
SO FAR NINETY PERCENT OF THE
AGENCIES THAT WE'VE BEEN TO HAVE
SAID THAT WE.
IN THE INDEPENDENT SECURITY
ASSESSMENT PROCESS HAVE HELP
THEM BETTER UNDERSTAND THE CYBER
RISK IN THEIR NETWORK.
I THINK THAT'S GOOD THING IF
YOU'RE NOT AWARE HE CAN'T FIX
IT.
.
AND AND.
MY FINAL POINT WOULD BE. THE.
COR FOR PARTNERS.
WE GET ALONG VERY WELL WITH THE
OTHER THREE PARTNERS AND I THINK
THAT. AS MR LEAVITT SAID
CYBERSECURITY.
IT'S A IT'S A JOURNEY AND IT'S A
VERY COMPLICATED JOURNEY
UNFORTUNATELY CYBERSECURITY IS
NOT A LINE ITEM ON A QUOTE IT'S
NOT A CHECKBOX
IT'S NOT A BINDER OVER IN THE
CORNER. IT'S REALLY COMPLICATED
AND IT'S A VERY LONG PATH. AND I
THINK THE FOUR CORE PARTNERS WHO
ARE WORKING VERY WELL TOGETHER
AND ADDING ADDITIONAL PARTNERS
IN THE PROCESS AND I THINK WE'RE
MAKING SOME STRIDES DOWN THAT
PATH LETTER THAT WERE REALLY
GOING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I
THINK.
.
WE'RE.
AND DRAMATICALLY IMPROVING
CYBERSECURITY IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S GREAT BECAUSE I THINK WE
NEED TO PROTECT THE DATA THE
CITIZENS.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT
LIEUTENANT COLONEL PARSONS A
FINAL LET'S GO TO ALL THE LAST
PRESENT AS SCOTT ALL HOLLAND WHO
IS THE CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MADAM
CHAIR. AND UP MEMBERS MY NAME'S
CHIEF SCOTT HOW ONE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL AND
AND I BASICALLY WERE TWO HATS
THE FIRST THAT IS AS CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER AND I'M
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE C. H. P.'S
IT. AND MAKE SURE WERE SECURE
AND THEN THE SECOND HAT WHICH
ACTUALLY SCARES THE GUY WITH THE
FIRST THAT. IS OVERSEE OUR
COMPUTER CRIMES INVESTIGATIONS
UNIT BECAUSE I SEE ALL THE STUFF
THAT GOES WRONG AND WANT TO MAKE
SURE IT DOESN'T GO WRONG ON MY
OWN NETWORK.
BUT I THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE I WANT TO
START WITH PAINTING A PICTURE OF
WHERE WE WERE A COUPLE YEARS AGO
AND WHERE WE ARE TODAY. BECAUSE
WHEN I LOOK AT HOW WE APPROACH
COMPUTER CRIMES INVESTIGATIONS
WE BASICALLY WE GET A CALL OF
MINUTES THAT. WE RESPOND TO THAT
AGENCY WOULD INVESTIGATE THAT
CRIME AND THEN CD TEASE
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICE
WOULD BE NOTIFIED AND THEY TAKE
A STEP.
INFORMATION WE GAIN FROM AT
INTELLIGENCE WE LEARNED DID NOT
GO ANYWHERE.
TODAY WHEN WE GET A CALL AS SOON
AS WE START THAT INVESTIGATION
IF WE HAVE ANY INTELLIGENCE THAT
COULD BE A PHISHING EMAIL
ADDRESS THAT WE NEED TO WHAT
LOOK OUT FOR COULD BE A BAD
WEBSITE. THAT INFORMATION GETS
PUSHED OF THE CAL SICK WHICH
THEN PUSHES OUT INCLUDING THE
SECURITY OPERATIONS CENTER SO
PEOPLE CAN BE PROACTIVE AND WE
CAN START DEFENDING OURSELVES
RATHER THAN PLAYING CATCH UP
WITH IT.
AND I THINK THE FACT THAT THAT
THAT SHARING OF INFORMATION HAS
REALLY MOVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FROM A REACTIVE MODE.
OF SOMETHING HAPPENED AND NOW
WE'RE PLAYING CATCH UP TO A THEY
WERE GETTING INDICATORS OF
SOMETHING GOING ON. WE NEED TO
TAKE SOME ACTION AND WE HAVE THE
PARTNERS IN PLACE TO ACTUALLY
TAKE THAT AIM THAT ACTION AND A
GREAT PART OF THE CAL SIC IS A
SURE WAY BEYOND THE STATE
ENTERPRISE LEVEL. AND SO ALL THE
LOCAL PARTNERS AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS AND EVERYBODY ELSE CAN
GAIN THAT INFORMATION THAT WE
SHARE.
I I WANT TO SPEND MY TIME REALLY
WALKING THROUGH SOME.
STACKS AS FAR AS WHAT WE GET
INVOLVED AND IN THE AC INCIDENTS
THAT WE.
INVESTIGATE AND I'M GONNA DO A
COMPARISON BETWEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
GIVE A GOOD IDEA THE TRENDS THAT
WE'RE SEEING.
BUT I THINK IT ALSO DOES A GOOD
JOB PAINTING THE PICTURE OF THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'RE MAKING.
SO. CALIFORNIA USES THE
CALIFORNIA COMPLIANCE AND
SECURITY INCIDENT REPORTING
SYSTEM THE CAL CAESAR SYSTEM TO
START A TO MAKE NOTIFICATIONS OF
INFORMATION SECURITY INCIDENTS
EVERY STATE DEPARTMENT IS.
ONLINE WITH THAT SYSTEM AND THE
BEAUTIFUL PART ABOUT THAT SYSTEM
IS AS SOON AS A DEPARTMENT MAKES
A REPORT THAT REPORT COMES TO
THE CHP. IT GOES TO THE CAL SICK
IT GOES TO TECHNOLOGY.
EVERYBODY KNOWS AT THE SAME TIME
THAT A DISSIDENT A STARTING NOW
REALIZE WITHIN THAT SYSTEM IT
MIGHT BE A PAPER BASED
INFORMATION SECURITY LOSS IN
WHICH CASE INFORMATION SECURITY
OFFICE WOULD BE THE ONLY FOLKS
THAT WOULD FOLLOW UP ON IT. BUT
THEY HAVE THAT INFORMATION
IMMEDIATELY IF IT'S CRIMINAL WE
WILL IMMEDIATELY JUMP ON BOARD
WITH IT IF THERE'S FOLLOW UP OR
INTELLIGENCE IN NEEDS TO BE
SHARED. HOW SICK IS ON BOARD
RIGHT AWAY KNOWING THAT HEY
SOMETHING'S COMING AND THEN
WE'RE TALKING AND SHARING THAT
INFORMATION? AND SO AS WE LOOK
AT THE TRENDS THAT WE'RE SEEING
BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE DID SEE AN
INCREASE PLAN OVERALL CAL
CAESAR'S REPORTS WE WENT FROM
SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY ONE TO
EIGHT HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT. BUT
REMEMBER WITHIN THOSE REPORTS
THAT INCLUDES THINGS LIKE PAPER
LOSS OF PERSONAL INFORMATION
INCLUDES OF THEFT OR LOSS OF
EQUIPMENT INCLUDING CELLPHONES.
SO PURPOSES OF TODAY WHEN I CAN
REALLY DO IS TAKE THAT THAT BIG
GLOBAL.
STATISTIC AND REALLY FOCUS ON
FOR COOPER THREE CATEGORIES MALL
WHERE INFECTIONS THAT HIT STATE
COMPUTERS.
A SOCIAL ENGINEERING AND FISHING
AND THE DENIAL OF SERVICE
ATTACKS AND I THINK THAT'LL PAIN
A VERY GOOD PICTURE.
SO WHEN WE DID GET TO THOSE KEY
CATEGORIES ACTUALLY HAVE GOOD
NEWS WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR MALL
WHERE INFECTIONS INFECTIONS ON
STATE COMPUTERS WE SIDE DROP
BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BY TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT.
WE WENT FROM FIFTY EIGHT. AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO FORTY THREE
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
I THINK IT'S AN INDICATOR OF
PROGRESS AND ANY TIME YOU HAVE
INFECTIONS GOING DOWN IT'S A
REALLY GOOD THING.
SOME MORE GOOD NEWS AND I THINK
THIS IS REALLY REALLY
SIGNIFICANT WE SAW SEVENTY NINE
PERCENT DECREASE IN RANSOMWARE
SEVENTY NINE PERCENT WE ALL KNOW
WHAT THE GLOBAL TREND HAS BEEN
OVER THE LAST YEAR IT IS NOT
BEEN PRETTY AND IT HAS BEEN
ACCELERATING STRAIGHT UP. IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WE ACTUALLY AT
TWENTY FOUR CASES OF RANSOMWARE
ON STATE ASSETS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. WE HAD FIVE.
I THINK THAT SHOWS GREAT
PROGRESS.
UNFORTUNATELY I CAN'T SAY WERE
DOWN IN ALL CATEGORIES
WHICH TAKES ME TO SOCIAL
ENGINEERING AND FISHING AND I
DON'T THINK ANY OF US ARE
SURPRISED THAT THAT NUMBER IS
NOT DOWN. AND IT WAS INTERESTING
WE RECENTLY WERE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT FISHING IN
THE FACT THAT ARE OUR NUMBER WAS
UP AND WE'RE HAVING A LITTLE
DEBATE ABOUT IS THAT A GOOD SIGN
OR A BAD SIGN.
BUT LET ME PUT FISHING IN
CONTEXT I READ A REPORT RECENTLY
THAT CAME FROM FISH ME. AND IT
SAID IN THE LAST YEAR FISHING
ATTEMPTS I'VE GONE UP SIXTY FIVE
PERCENT.
THAT IS A HUGE INCREASE AND TO
PUT THAT SIXTY FIVE PERCENT IN
CONTEXT.
ANOTHER RECENT REPORT I READ IT
SAYS THERE'S ABOUT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION. UNITS THAT'S THAT
AGAIN ONE POINT FIVE MILLION NEW
FISHING SITES ESTABLISHED
MONTHLY.
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
PHISHING EMAILS OUT THERE THAT
NUMBER IS BEEN INCREASING
EXPONENTIALLY.
WE'VE GONE UP THIRTY SIX PERCENT
IN THE STATE.
FROM THIRTY SIX
THE FORTY NINE.
VERY LOW NUMBERS.
BUT WE DUG A LITTLE BIT DEEPER
IN THAT TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT
OKAY.
HOW MANY OF THOSE ACTUALLY
RESULT IN INFECTION?
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE HAD THIRTY
SIX REPORTED FISHING INCIDENTS
TWENTY.
OF THEM WORK RESULTED IN
INFECTION.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE HAD FORTY
NINE INCIDENTS REPORTED HIGHER
NUMBER. BUT ONLY EIGHTEEN MALL
WHERE INFECTIONS.
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT.
FISHING IS GOING UP. BUT OUR
INFECTIONS RESULTING FROM
FISHING IS GOING DOWN.
AND I THINK IT IT SHOWS THAT
FOLKS ARE REPORTING MORE OFTEN.
BUT THE REASON THEY'RE REPORTING
MORE OFTEN IS THE REPORTING AND
NOT FALLING VICTIM.
AND ANY TIME WE CAN SAY
REPORTING AND I'M FALLING VICTIM
THAT IS REALLY GOOD. AND I THINK
WHEN WHEN.
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENTS BEEN
LOOKING AT THE INDEPENDENT
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS THEY'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN A REDUCTION.
IN THE NUMBER OF.
FOLKS THAT FALL FOR THEIR FAKE%
EMAIL SO THEY SENT TO TEST FOX.
SO IT IT IT'S CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING ACROSS
THE ENTERPRISE.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE'VE SEEN
AS WE ACTUALLY SAW REDUCTION IN
DENIAL OF SERVICE ATTACKS WE
WENT FROM FOUR TO THREE.
VERY SMALL NUMBERS.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT PUT
ALL THIS IN PERSPECTIVE AND.
I WAS READING A EUROPEAN UNION
AGENCY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS EUROPE WILL.
REPORT FROM LATE LAST YEAR AND
THEY SAID RANSOMWARE CONTINUES
TO BE ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT
MALL WHERE THREATS IN TERMS OF
THE VARIETY AND RANGE OF ITS
VICTIMS AND THE DAMAGE DONE. AND
I DON'T THINK I NEED TO CONVINCE
ANYBODY HERE OF THE DAMAGE THAT
RANSOMWARE CAN DO. AT AND THEY
HIGHLIGHT THAT THESE ATTACKS OF
HIGHLIGHTED HOW CAN ACTIVITIES
OR DIGITAL HYGIENE STANDARDS AND
SECURITY PRACTICES CAN ALLOW
SUCH A THREAT TO QUICKLY SPREAD.
AND EXPAND THE ATTACK VECTOR.
BUT WHEN YOU PUT THOSE NUMBERS
IN CONTEXT.
OF WHAT'S GOING ON WORLDWIDE
WERE MAKING EXTREMELY GREAT
PROGRESS WITH IT BUT IT ALSO
REINFORCES THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
ACTIONS WE'RE TAKING IN
CALIFORNIA. GOING BACK TO THOSE
INDEPENDENT SECURITY ASSESSMENTS
TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THOSE
VULNERABILITIES OF WHERE FOLKS
CAN GET AND SO WE CAN BE
PROACTIVE AND CLOSE THOSE
STORES.
ANOTHER TREND THAT EUROPE OR THE
EUROPOL REPORT POINTS OUT IS
FISHING THE MOST COMMONLY
FACILITATED THREATS WERE SOCIAL
ENGINEERING ATTACKS AND CYBER
FACILITATED FRAUDS SOME REPORTS
SUGGEST ATTACKERS USE EMAIL TO
CONTACT THEIR VICTIMS NINETY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE TIME.
IS THE EASY WAY TO GET IN AND
ONE SAY SOMEONE GETS THEIR ALL
LIFE THROUGH ITS CLICK.
OR PROVIDE INFORMATION AND
THEREIN.
THE SCARIEST THING IS A CHAU OF
KNOWING THAT I'VE WE'VE GOT
ELEVEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES IN THE
CHP AND ONLY TAKES ONE TO INVITE
THE BAD GUY IN. WITH THE MANY
MANY FISHING EMAILS THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
AND I ACTUALLY DO A COMPARISON
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE CHP WORKS
TIRELESSLY TO.
EDUCATE OUR DRIVERS AS FAR AS
THE DANGER OF TEXTING AND
DRIVING TO MAKE OUR HIGHWAYS
SAFER. AND I THINK WE REALLY
NEED TO LOOK AT FISHING EMAIL
AND USER EDUCATION IN THE SAME
WAY THAT IS NOT A ONE TIME FIX
BUT IT'S AN ONGOING CAMPAIGN
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE. BECAUSE
THEY KEEP CHANGING ALL THEIR
EMAILS MATTER FACT I GOT ONE
JUST. TWO DAYS AGO THAT
BASICALLY SAID ONE OF MY
ACCOUNTS HAVE BEEN LOCKED.
AND IT WAS THE COMPANY LOGO WAS
THE COMPANY TAXED IT LOOKED
REALLY REALLY GOOD.
THE THING THAT BECAUSE MY
INITIAL BOSS I'D JUST BEEN ON
THAT ACCOUNT AND I'M LIKE MY
COUNTS NOT LOCKED. AND THEN I
LOOKED A LITTLE DEEPER AND SURE
ENOUGH IT WAS A FISHING EMAIL.
IT BUT AS WE TALKED EARLIER TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IT'S NOT A
ONE TIME FIXES AN ONGOING THING
YOU SPEEDERS TERM IT'S REALLY A
MARATHON. AND IT'S REALLY HAVING
THE RIGHT COMBINATION OF PEOPLE
PROCESS AND TECHNOLOGY.
AND THE EXCITING PART IS WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH PEOPLE PROCESS AND
TECHNOLOGY TODAY IN THE PARTNERS
ARE DOING A FABULOUS JOB OF
DOING WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
REALLY ADDRESS THESE THINGS.
I THINK BE OTHER PERSPECTIVE I
WANT TO PROVIDE THIS MORNING IS
FROM THE CHAU.
THE EFFORTS THAT ARE ARE
OCCURRING WITH THE FOUR CORE ARE
MAKING GREAT PROGRESS WHEN I
TALK TO MY PEERS OUT THERE.
CIO'S ACROSS STATE DEPARTMENTS
OR TAKING SECURITY SERIOUSLY.
THEY'RE REALLY FOCUSING ON IT
AND THEY'RE WORKING HARD TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS.
IT'S A REALLY GOOD THING WHEN
CIO'S HAVE CONVERSATIONS TO SAY
HEY YOU HAVE TO BE CP LAST YEAR
ON CYBERSECURITY. WHAT DID YOU
DO BECAUSE I NEED TO DO
SOMETHING SIMILAR?
WERE REALLY SHARING THOSE
LESSONS LEARNED IN MAKING
PROGRESS.
AND AND I THINK THE OTHER OTHER
INTERESTING THING IS THAT I KNOW
THAT WHEN THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT STARTED INDEPENDENT
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS I IT I
CAN'T SAY THAT EVERYBODY WAS
OPENED ARMS AND EXCITED ABOUT
SOMEONE COMING IN AND DOING AN
ASSESSMENT.
BUT BUT I'VE USED AN ANALOGY
WITH CIO'S THAT THEY SEEM TO
REALLY HAVE ADOPTED AND BASED
ON%
THE MILITARY'S EXPERIENCE THEY
REALLY HAVE. AYE I WAS DRIVING
INTO WORK ONE DAY AND LOOK OVER
AND I SAW A BIG RIG WITH A.
GAS CAP.
NO IT'S NOT A HIGHWAY PATROL
THING LOOKING GAS CAPS ON ON
FUEL TANKS BUT THE REASON THAT
IT CAUGHT MY ATTENTION WAS IT
WAS A LOCKING GAS CAP.
HE WASN'T.
SO WE HAD A TRUCKING COMPANY
THAT NEW THE THREAT OF A FUEL
THEFT.
HAD PAID FOR A LOCKING GAS CAP
BUT SOMEONE HAD LEFT THE KEY IN
THE CASKET.
AND I BET IF I ASK THE OWNER
THAT IF THEY WANTED TO KEY IN
THE GAS CAP HE WOULD HAVE SAID
NO. WE NEED FIX THAT.
BUT I THINK INDEPENDENT SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS ARE THE SAME THING
IT PROVIDES DEPARTMENTS A
ROADMAP TO SAY HATE TO HAVE A
GAS CAP WITH A KEY IT. TO OUR
DOOR THAT'S OPEN DRIVE SOMETHING
IT WAS MIS CONFIGURED OR DID IT
STAFF MISS SOMETHING OR OTHER
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
THAT WE'RE NOT DOING. AND REALLY
PUT IT ON THE ROAD MAP SO WE CAN
FIX SOME.
IT IT'S INCREDIBLY HELPFUL WITH
IT.
AND IN CLOSING I JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERS WE HAVE AND WE JUST
LOOK AT THE WORKING RELATIONSHIP
THAT WE HAVE BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY. A WE ASK
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENTS AND AND
YOU SAW THE THE STRATEGIC
ALLIANCE THAT ARE EXECUTIVE
LEVEL. THEY'RE ALL ON BOARD ALL
SUPPORTIVE AND I GOTTA SAY THAT
AT THE OPERATIONAL LEVEL. MY
WIFE IS JEALOUS OF THE TIME WE
SPEND TOGETHER.
AND BUT BUT WE LAUGHED ABOUT
THAT BUT I THINK IT'S PAID GREAT
DIVIDENDS AND WE'VE SEEN THE
PROGRESS BECAUSE IT'S REALLY A
TEAM THAT'S WORKING TOGETHER TO
IMPROVE CYBERSECURITY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND AND I THINK I'D
BE A MASSIVE WE DIDN'T
ACKNOWLEDGE THE THE FOR SIDE OF
THE GOVERNOR WITH THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER OF GETTING THIS
COLLABORATION STARTED. AND ALSO
THANK THE COMMITTEE ESPECIALLY
OUR OUR CO CHAIRS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND YOUR ROLE IN HOW
YOU'VE HELPED US REALLY PROGRESS
ALONG THE WAY.
AND AS PETER SAID THIS IS A
MARATHON. AND I THINK OUR
BIGGEST CHALLENGE IS REALLY
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY IS
REALLY AWARE THAT CYBERSECURITY
IS NOT A ONE TIME FIX.
IT'S A PROG A PROCESS AND WE
NEED TO KEEP WORKING ON IT.
BECAUSE I THINK SOMETIMES WE
LOOK AT THINGS AND SAY OH YAK
CHECK THAT BOX WERE DONE. WHEN
WITH THE WAY THE THREAT IS
CHANGING I MEAN SHOOT IN THE
TIME WE'VE BEEN HERE TODAY HOW
MANY MILLIONS OF DIFFERENT
THREATS OF COME UP.
THAT WE NEED TO BE AWARE OF BUT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND.
APPRECIATE THE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT WITHOUT
A LIKE TO OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS
I BELIEVE UNCLE CHAIR WHEN YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS. I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION YOU WERE ALL VERY
THOROUGH AND AND.
ACTUALLY OF TWO QUESTIONS AND
BOTH FOR.
PETER. I WORK BUT THANK YOU FOR
THOSE.
THOROUGH PRESENTATIONS.
TYPE ONE IT'S AN OCD TO GOING
TO OFFER ASSISTANCE TO THE
DEPARTMENTS TO ACHIEVE.
AB TEN TWENTY TWO.
INVENTORY.
FROM A TRAINING AND.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
STANDPOINT SO THEY CAN IDENTIFY.
YOU CRITICAL SYSTEMS AND I
CERTAINLY.
WE'VE ACTUALLY.
REACH OUT TO.
JUST.
THEMSELVES AND LOOKING AT DOING
A WORKSHOP ON HOPEFULLY.
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS I
SPECIFICALLY COVERING.
HOW TO DO?
DECLASSIFICATION WHICH IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
IDENTIFYING A CRITICAL SYSTEMS.
AND WE'RE ALSO GONNA HAVE A
ADDITIONAL WORKSHOPS THIS YEAR
ON THAT.
TYPE OF ACTIVITY AS WELL AS
BUSINESS IMPACT ANALYSIS HOW
YOU.
IDENTIFYING THOSE SYSTEMS IS
PARAMOUNT.
SO THEY CAN ACTUALLY PUT IT
WITHIN THE HAVE THE.
THE DOCUMENT ITSELF SO FROM THAT
ASPECT YES.
OKAY AND AND.
AGAIN A LOT OF PROGRESS.
AND THAT THIS PROBABLY PUT YOU
A LITTLE BIT ON THE SPOT MAYBE
YOU DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER BUDGET
WHEN I LOOK AT THE ASSESSMENTS
AND THE AUDITS IN THE
PARTNERSHIPS AND YOU KNOW
SWITCHING OVER TO.
OFFICE THREE SIXTY FIVE WHICH
OFTEN OBVIOUSLY THAT MAKES IT.
FOR GETTING THE EXPERTISE FROM
THE PRIVATE SECTOR THAT'S GREAT
AND ALL THE BECAUSE IT'S ALL THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH DEPARTMENTS
BUT.
WHY ARE YOU KNOW WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S DOING AIR DO YOU
KNOW WHAT ANY OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL?
OFFICES ARE DOING ARE THEY
BENEFITING FROM ALL THIS.
EXPERIENCE WITH OVER THE.
THAT'S GOING ON IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
YOU CAN'T ANSWER I UNDERSTOOD
NO NO I I CAN I CAN GIVE A.
GENERAL ANSWER.
IF THERE ARE ACKNOWLEDGED GAPS
IN TERMS OF WHAT MY OFFICE ARE
OVERSEAS.
THERE IS CONFLICTING.
STATUTE.
FOLKS CAN POINT TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT CITIES CAN POINT TO. A
STATUTE SAYING THAT THEY'RE
INDEPENDENT ENTIRELY THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN JURISDICTION THINGS ON
THOSE LINES.
AND THEN WE CAN POINT TO THE
SAME FIFTY THREE HUNDRED AND OUR
STATUE AND SAY WELL. IT'S IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY CLEAR THERE
CERTAINLY GRAY AREA.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING.
WITH LEADERSHIP.
TO BRING MORE FOLKS IN.
THAT IS ARE WHAT ARE IN THAT
GRAY AREA.
.
S. CERTAINLY SOME FLOWS.
BUT WE'RE WE'RE CONTINUING MAKE
STRIDES IN THAT.
.
AND I I WOULD NOT HAVE AN ANSWER
ON. THE STATE LEGISLATURE MORE
TAKE HEART WITH THAT.
IT'S.
FOR ESPECIALLY THOSE IN THE
GRAY AREAS LIKE A CALM THERE
IT'S VOLUNTARY WIENER DEFTLY
ENCOURAGE.
FOLKS TO PARTICIPATE.
OUR DOORS ARE OPEN.
OUR POLICIES IS PUBLISHED.
ARE METRIC IS GOING BE
PUBLISHED I THINK THIS NEXT WEEK
OR SO.
.
WE ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO UTILIZE
THAT IT'S A LOT OF EFFORT.
THERE BUT WE WE DON'T COVER ONE.
AYE AYE PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THIS
IS THE CDT SOCK.
HUGE MAN CAPABILITY WERE SEEN
NOT USE ALL UTILIZING THE STATE
WIDE AREA NETWORK I SEE JEN. I
HAVE NO VISIBILITY INTO THEIR
NETWORKS ARE SYSTEM.
THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT IS.
AND NOT EVERY ENTITY DOES THAT
I UTILIZE THOSE SERVICES
SO WE'RE CONTINUALLY TRIED TO
BRING US FOLKS IN.
AND BRING THEM OVER BUT.
.
IT'S THAT'S UNFORTUNATE LIKE
IT'S A HOME.
AND TO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE HAS A
QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAD A
FOR COMMANDER TRASH.
IN YOUR TESTIMONY YOU DISCUSSED
THE SUCCESS THE DEPARTMENTS HAD
IN ELIMINATING THE KASPERSKY.
ANTIVIRUS PRODUCTS FROM STATE
COMPUTERS AND I WONDERED ABOUT
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS THAT
YOU FOLLOWED AND IDENTIFYING
THAT AS A THREAT DID YOU MAKE
YOUR OWN ASSESSMENT OR DID YOU
RELY ON. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND
IDENTIFYING THAT PARTICULAR
PRODUCT.
A VERY GOOD QUESTION I'M IT WAS.
A LITTLE OF EVERYTHING BECAUSE
ONCE WE SAW WE NOW UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE ACCESS TO CLASSIFIED. DATA
SO WHAT WE HAD BEEN SEEN WAS OF
A LOT OF TALKING AROUND THE
SUBJECT IN SAYING IT IT LOOKS
BAD AND AND THAT KIND OF THING.
SO WHEN WE FINALLY SAW WHAT WHAT
WOULD THE PIVOT POINT WAS IS
GSA.
FEDERAL GSA HAD OF HAD A A.
PRESS CONFERENCE.
TO TO SAY THEY'RE TAKING BECAUSE
PERSKY OFF OF THEIR LIST AND
THAT RAISE RED FLAGS WITH US SO
AT THAT POINT. ME MY MY ANALYSTS
LIKE WE STARTED TALKING TO D. H.
US AND I'D THE DOD WE HAD.
WHO CAN CALL PARSONS OF HIS
FOLKS CHECK ON THE DOD SIDE HAD
YOU WE HAVE HIGH CIDER
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION?
THAT IS IS MORE YOU KNOW IT IS
ACTUALLY MORE PINPOINTED AND IN
FACT THERE WAS.
WE WERE ABLE TO TALK THROUGH
THAT WITH DHS AND GET ENOUGH
INFORMATION.
DOWN AT THE FORUM FOR OF A OF A
FISH USE ONLY LEVEL TO ACTUALLY
SAY THERE WAS SOME SPECIFIC AND
REAL THREATS THERE. SO WITH THAT
I TOOK THAT TO MY DIRECTOR
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE THOUGHT.
AT THAT POINT I FELT IT WAS AN
IMMINENT THREAT BASED ON THE
INFORMATION WE HAD AND I ASK
DIRECTOR TONG AND DIRECTOR
GALLUCCI.
TO MAKE THAT ASSESSMENT BUT
ONCE WE ALL TALK ABOUT IT OF OF
THE COLLECTIVE YES WE NEED TO
RESIST TO A HIGHER LEVEL.
SO THERE ARE. OTHER.
SENSITIVE SOFTWARE PRODUCTS THAT
ARE MADE BY COMPANIES WITH TIES
TO RUSSIA.
THE FOR EXAMPLE A VIRTUAL
PRIVATE NETWORK SOFTWARE BUT YOU
HAVE SIMILAR CONCERNS ABOUT
THOSE KINDS OF PRODUCTS.
WE DO.
.
AND THAT THE CHALLENGE WE FACE
RIGHT NOW IS WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING. AT THE SAME LEVEL THAT
THEY HAD AS KASPERSKY DEAD AND
WE CONTINUE TO MONITOR THAT
DAILY AND I MEAN DALY. AYE WE
LOOK FOR THAT WE ARE A
CONSISTENTLY LOOKING AT THE
CLASSIFIED REPORTS
AND TALKING TO OUR FEDERAL
COUNTERPARTS.
TO ENSURE THAT ONCE IF WHEN
THERE IS SOMETHING SPECIFIC THAT
WE ACT ON IT RIGHT AWAY.
ANOTHER QUESTION FOR MISTER
HOWLAND.
IN YOUR TESTIMONY YOU WERE
DISCUSSING THE FACT THAT MOST OF
THE METRICS ARE TRAINING IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION EXCEPT THOSE
FOR FISHING ALTHOUGH. I FISHING
ATTACKS.
SUCCESSFUL FISHING TAX ARE UP
THEY ARE UP TO THE EXTENT THAT.
OVERALL PHISHING ATTACKS ARE
AND SO THAT'S KIND OF GOOD NEWS
AS WELL.
HOWEVER I REQUEST ABOUT THE
METHODOLOGY THAT WE'RE USING ON
THAT METRIC BECAUSE.
BY DEFINITION IF YOU'RE LOOKING
AT A FISHING ATTACK YOU ONLY
KNOW ABOUT IT IF SOMEONE.
SUCCESSFULLY RECOGNIZES IT AS AN
ATTACK YOU KNOW BY DEFINITE WIN
OR THEY'RE UNSUCCESSFUL AND THE
ATTACK RESULTS IN AN INFECTION
THAN LEADER YOU CAN.
I DO A POSTMORTEM AND DETERMINE
THAT THE INFECTION WAS A RESULT
OF THE FISHING EMAIL. A BUT
OTHER IS NOT A NO QUESTION ABOUT
THE METHODOLOGY IS YOU KNOW
FIRST OF ALL YOU'VE GOT A LARGE
CATEGORY OF USERS THAT DIDN'T
SUCCESSFULLY RECOGNIZES A TAXI
WOULDN'T KNOW ABOUT THOSE. AND
THEN SECOND OF ALL SOME OF THE
SUCCESSFUL ATTACKS
WILL BE AFTER THINGS LIKE THAT
YOU CAN'T DETECT LATER LOOK FOR
EXAMPLE LAST PERSONAL
INFORMATION OR PASSWORDS OR
THINGS LIKE THAT. THAT DON'T
RESULT IN AN INFECTION THAT THAT
YOU CAN TRACE BACK TO THE EMAIL
SO I WONDER HOW YOU HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THE IN THOSE
METRICS WHEN THOSE.
THOSE PROBLEMS ARE ARE EXTENT
SO THAT THERE'S ALWAYS THE
UNKNOWN YOU'RE CORRECT ON THAT
ABSOLUTELY.
THOSE METRICS ARE BASED ON CAL
CAESAR'S REPORTS ACTUALLY
REPORTED EVENTS AND SO WHENWE
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF REPORTED
FISHING EVENTS. UP AND THEN WE
LOOKED AT THE NUMBER OF.
MALL WHERE INFECTIONS THAT WERE
RELATED TO PHISHING ATTACKS AS
FAR AS THOSE NUMBERS SO DID WE
CAPTURE HUNDRED PERCENT. NO
ABSOLUTELY NOT BUT I THINK WHEN
IT'S THE REALLY THAT MALL WHERE
INFECTION IS PROBABLY THE MOST
ACCURATE ONE. BECAUSE WHEN
SOMETHING DOES HAPPEN AND THERE
IS.
CAO CAESAR'S REPORT AND WE DO
INVESTIGATE WE WERE LOOKING AT
THE CORRELATION BETWEEN THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS AND FISH
ITSELF OKAY WELL THE REASON I'M
INTERESTED IS BECAUSE I THINK
THE. INFECTION IS THE EASIEST.
THING TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT WHEN
IT COMES TO MALWARE BECAUSE I'M
SORRY A PHISHING ATTACKS
BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW WE HAD AN ENTERPRISE
LEVEL CAN INFLUENCE THE ABILITY
OF THE USER TO DO THINGS THAT
AFFECT THE SYSTEM BUT.
YOU KNOW THE OTHER TYPES OF
PHISHING ATTACKS WE REALLY HAVE
A LOT LESS CONTROL OVER AND IF
THE USER IS GOING TO. PUT.
SENSITIVE INFORMATION LIKE A
PASSWORD.
YOU KNOW THROUGH THE IN
RESPONSE TO FISHING ATTACK IN A
WEEK WE HAVE A LOT LESS.
INFLUENCE OVER THAT THE ONLY
THING WE CAN DO IS EDUCATE SO I
THINK THOSE ARE MORE A LOT MORE
PROBLEMATIC TO DEAL WITH OH OH
ABSOLUTELY IN YOU WHEN WE LOOK
AT OUR INCIDENTS WE WE HAD A
VARIETY OF INCIDENTS THEY
INCLUDED AN INFECTION ON. A
DESKTOP IT UNFORTUNATELY SOME
PEOPLE GAVE UP CREDENTIALS AND
THEN YOU HAVE ME MUCH MAILBOXES
TAKEN OVER AND THEN YOU'RE
CHASING THAT. IT BECOMES A MUCH
BIGGER INCIDENT SO YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ON YOU KNOW IF
WE CAN GET USERS. TO NOT DO THAT
CLICK I CALL MY* IF WE GET
THE THE CLICKERS NOT TO CLICK
AND FOLKS NOT TO PROVIDE
CREDENTIALS IT PIT STOPS IT
THERE BUT AS WE TALKED EARLIER
IT'S. HOW DO WE COMBINE
TECHNOLOGY TO STOP IT STOP IT
FROM GETTING TO THE USER IN THE
FIRST PLACE BUT MAKES OUR USERS
ARE WELL EDUCATED BECAUSE?
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT GOING TO GO ON
A PERCENT OF A. AND TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE REALLY SMART AND IT'S
REALLY HARD BECAUSE YOU LOOK AT
JUST THAT THE VOLUME OF EMAILS
WE ALL GET.
WE WE CRANK THEIR EMAILS WERE
JUST TRYING TO GET IT DONE AND
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE ALL TAKE
THE TIME WE NEED TO VERIFY THAT.
THAT REQUEST THE CLICK ON A LINK
FOR THAT REQUEST FOR A
CREDENTIAL.
WHERE WE GET INTO THE BIGGEST
TROUBLE IS LEGITIMATE?
AND SOMETIMES WE'RE JUST ON
AUTOPILOT AND BOOM WE GO IN AND
BAD THINGS HAPPEN AND THEN IT'S
WE NOW HAVE AN INSTANT TO DEAL
WITH PER.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU AND IF I MAY I
I JUST DON'T WANT ADDITIONAL A
COMPONENT TO THAT.
.
BUT THIS IS ALSO WHY WE LAYERED
DEFENSES AND DETECTION.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
NEO FISHING EMAILS.
.
STUFF GETS THROUGH.
THIS IS WHY WERE I DO INTERNAL
STANDS DOING THAT LARRY TEXAN
CAPABILITY WITHIN THE STATE YOU
PUT THROUGH SOCK.
AS WELL AS.
HAVE DEPARTMENTS AND ENTITIES
REQUIRED TO TO MONITOR ON
NETWORKS IN LAW HAVE LONG
MANAGEMENT.
SO THAT.
IF THERE IS A CREDENTIAL THEFT
WHICH WOULD NECESSARILY RESULT
AND FACTION.
YOU'RE GONNA SEE HOPEFULLY THE
ACTIVITY RESULTING FROM THAT
MISUSE OF CREDENTIALS AND THINGS
ALONG THOSE LINES
SO BY LAYERING THOSE DEFENSES
YOUR DISK IN REDUCING THE RISK
AT LEAST SO IF SOMEONE DOES
PROVIDE INFORMATION.
YOU CAN YOU CAN SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON.
THAT'S IMPORTANT AND I THINK.
FIREEYE PUBLISHED.
STATISTICALLY ABOUT A YEAR AGO
THURMOND DID REPORT THAT I'M OUT
OF ALL THE BREACHES THEY
INVESTIGATED. WAS ALMOST A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THEM HAD.
UP TODAY ANTI VIRUS.
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES THE
BRIDGES ARE FROM CREDENTIAL
THEFT AND THINGS ALONG THOSE
LINES SO.
WE'RE HOPING THAT ARE TEXAS
STRATEGY IS IS PROVIDING THAT
ARE LEAST ALLOWING US DETECT OUT
QUICKLY AND RESPOND TO.
INTERESTING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I HAVE A
COUPLE OF FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS.
IF I MAY GO TO OF COMMENDED
TRASH FIRST IN. COMMAND TRASHY
TALK TO A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
OUT REACH PROGRAM WAR OF. OVER
FIVE HUNDRED ENTITIES ARE LOCAL
OMINOUS PALLISER.
VIA BICU ARE PART OF THE
PROGRAM SO LET ME FIRST OFF COME
ON. A COMMAND YOU FOR THAT
BECAUSE IT IT'S A YOU KNOW IT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE LOOKING TO DO
AND THAT'S COLLABORATION WITH
THE LOCALS. AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. ARM.
NOW MY QUESTION IS OF THEIR FIVE
HUNDRED.
OR ENTITIES OR INDIVIDUALS ARE
IN PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE THE
STATE WHAT ARE SOME THE TYPICAL
INCIDENTS OR ARE THINGS THAT
THEY NEED HELP. WITH.
I AM. VERY GOOD QUESTION.
A. WELL AS I SAID IN MY MY A
STATEMENT.
THEY CAN RANGE ANYWHERE FROM
WEBSITE DEFACE HURTS A LOT OF
TIMES WILL ACTUALLY GET
INFORMATION OF A WEBSITE DEFACE
MEN IN THE REASON WHY SOME OF
THESE FOLKS ON NOBODY IS BECAUSE
IT'S NOT THE FRONT PAGE.
IT'S ONE OF THEIR BACK PAGES OR
ONE OF THE SECONDARY OUR THIRD
PAGES SO GET THIS INFORMATION
AND WILL CALL AND SAY HEY YOU
BETTER WEBSITE DEFACE MINIMAL
SELL WHAT WE DO KNOW THAT. AND
SO THEY'RE GOING TO FIND IT BUT
WE'VE GOT A COUPLE OF LARGE
CITIES IN THIS ONE IS A LITTLE
SCARY BUT WE GOT A COUPLE LARGE
CITIES THAT.
THEY HAVEN'T BOUGHT INTO THE
WHOLE.
GET MY HEAD OF SAND.
THERE WHAT IT THERE'S A LARGE
CITY IN THE.
SUCH CALIFORNIA THAT HAS HAD
ISSUES WITH FISHING AND MALWARE
ATTACKS
THAT THEY'VE COULD ACTUALLY
CALLED US AND SAID HEY.
A CAN YOU LOOK AT THIS STRING
FORCE WE'VE LOOKED AT IT AND
WE'VE SAID.
YET THAT'S FROM CHINA.
SO SORTS OF THINGS LIKE THAT I
AM WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD WE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME IN THE EDUCATION
SECTOR.
BECAUSE OF THE RESEARCH
COMPONENT AND YOU KNOW THEIR
SYSTEMS ARE MUCH MORE OPEN
BECAUSE THEY NEED THEM TO BE
OPEN TO TO DO RESEARCH SO WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME I I'M INTO
THE TERM BOTNET ACTIVITY. SO
WHAT HAPPENS S A LOT OF THE
COMPUTERS THAT ARE ON THEIR
NETWORKS HAVE BEEN TAKEN OVER.
AND THEN ARE BEING USED AS KIND
OF A CHAIN TO DO OTHER TYPE OF
NEFARIOUS ACTIVITY SO WE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME. A COLON UP YEAH I
SEE ISSUE EDU A AND ET USED
CATER TWELVE. AND SAY HEY YOU
GOT SOME.
THESE COMPUTERS THAT ARE AYE
INFECTED AND THEY GO BACK IN THE
OLD YEP AND THEY HAVE A FIX OF.
SO IT RANGES AND AND THINGS.
WE'VE WE DO YOU KNOW I WANT TO
TAKE ALL AND NOT HIGHLIGHT
FISHING.
AND JUST TO HIGHLIGHT THIS.
THERE'S BEEN A A VERY YOU KNOW.
THE FIERY ALSO WHEN THERE'S BEEN
A COUPLE REPORTS IT SAID
PHISHING. ATTACKS TRENDS FOR
THIS YEAR ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO TO GET LARGER. AND IT'S
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO RULES OF
ENGAGEMENTS OUTSIDE SOMEONE
MENTION WHAT KIND OF ACTORS I
THINK WAS YOU ON.
IF SOMEONE CHAU ABOUT WHAT KIND
OF ACTORS.
IN OUR NATION STATES NATION
STATES THAT YOU KNOW DON'T HAVE
OF RULES OF ENGAGEMENT WE DO
THEY DON'T.
AND IF THEY'RE NOT GETTING
CAUGHT OR IF THERE ARE NO
CONSEQUENCES WHY STOP.
SO THE POINT IS IN AND WITH THE
LAYERED APPROACH WITH THE TEAM
APPROACH THAT'S WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR US TO SEE STUFF
AT.
STATE LEVEL AND SEEING AND STATE
ENTITIES OR IF I SEE IT IN THE
EDUCATION OR THE BANKING SECTOR.
TO PASS THAT INFORMATION OVER TO
PETER AND HIS FOLKS SO THAT WE
CAN GET THAT LATER APPROACHES
START LOOKING MORE ACTIVELY AT
THAT. AND THAT'S WHY IT'S ALSO
LARGELY IMPORTANT FOR US.
TO NOT JUST TAKE THAT THREAT
INFORMATION WERE GIVING IT BUT
THE CORRELATED AND SAY THIS
DATA.
DIFFICULT LOOKS AT EDUCATION
SECTOR AND THEN TALK TO THEM
SPECIFICALLY SO. I'M A IN
ENCLOSING ON THAT PIECE IT IS
THERE'S THERE'S A GAMUT OF IT I
WOULD TELL YOU PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST.
AMOUNT IS IS WEBSITE DEFACE
MINTS AND.
.
THE.
BUTTON AND ACTIVITY SO WOULD IT
BE CORRECT TO SAY THAT.
DIS IN EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
HAVE NO SAFEGUARDS AGAINST
CYBERATTACKS WHATSOEVER DO THEY
HAVE A LITTLE MINIMAL LEVEL OF
FUN. YES REGARDS IT AND WHAT YOU
NORMALLY FIND SIR IS THAT THESE
ARE THE. THE EITHER THE THE
COMPUTERS IN THE RESEARCH LAB.
BECAUSE THEY THEIR THEY HAVE
LOW WERE.
DEFENSES ON THEM THEN THEY
WOULD LIKE ON THAT ON A FACULTY
MEMBER AND AND ON THE NETWORK ON
THEIR IT'S MORE OF THE RESEARCH
CAPABILITY ONES THAT HAVE A IT'S
NOT THAT THEY DON'T. THEY JUST
HAVE MINIMAL.
NO THE OBJECTIVE OBVIOUSLY IS TO
CAN REACH OUT TO MORE OF THESE
US ENTITIES TO BASICALLY PROVIDE
HELP.
I'M SU IF THAT IS THE CASE IN A
WOULD THE DEPARTMENT BE
ALLOCATING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO THAT.
ARE OUT REACH PROGRAM OR WAS
THAT OREGON DE BEING DONE NOW IS
THAT YES THAT THAT'S THE THE
PLAN THAT DUMB WE HAVE THAT TIME
I'VE WORKED WITH DIRECTOR
GALLUCCI ON. WHERE YOU KNOW AS
WE ARE? GAINING GROUND IN GIVING
MORE OF THOSE.
PARTNERS IF YOU WILL EDNA
WORKING THROUGH THAT BUSINESS
PLAN TO SHOW THAT THIS IS BEING
EFFECTIVE YOU KNOW AND QUITE
FRANKLY I'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO
SHOW. THAT WE'RE MAKING NO
PROGRESS AND HERE'S WHY WE NEED
MORE RESOURCES BUT YES WE'VE
TALKED A DIRT OF THE DIRECTOR
ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A DIRECTOR A
CRUISE I HAVE YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE CLOUT WILL YOU REFERRING. TO
THE.
CAO CLUB.
YES IT WAS CALCLOUD NOW ALSO
INCLUDES AN ADDITION A
GOVERNMENT CLOUD SERVICES
COMMERCIAL CLOSER TO YOU IN
GENERAL ARE. FROM A. ON
CYBERSECURITY STANDPOINT WOOD UC
FIREWOOD CAO CLOUT TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL OR WOOD CALCLOUD
PROVIDE THE MOST.
ON SAFE ENVIRONMENT.
FOR A STATE AGENCIES FOR
EXAMPLE OFF FROM A CYBERSECURITY
STANDPOINT AYE YES IN FACT
WE'VE.
ESTABLISHING CAME OUT THE
TECHNOLOGY LETTER LAST YEAR THAT
MANDATES THAT REALLY FOR GOING
TO USE COMMERCIAL CLOUD SERVICES
DOES NOT ONLY NEED TO BE
PROCURED THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY BUT ALSO THROUGH OUR
INTERCONNECTION INFRASTRUCTURE.
SIGN UP.
ON OUR STATEWIDE NETWORK OR
THROUGH OUR SECURITY OPERATIONS
CENTER SO WE CAN MONITOR AND
MANAGE MALICIOUS ACTIVITY AS IT
COMES THROUGH SO THAT IS NOW A
TECHNOLOGY POLICY IN THE STATE.
PROVOKES UNDER THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH
GOT IT NOW IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THEY ARE NOT ALL. AGENCIES
IN CALIFORNIA USE CALCLOUD SO
WHAT IS THE BREAKDOWN.
THAT.
LET'S A PERCENTAGE WISE HOW
HOMIES AGE STATE AGENCIES ARE
USING SOMETHING OTHER THAN CAO
CLOUT WELL THERE ARE STILL A
NUMBER STATE AGENCIES THAT ARE
USING COMMERCIAL CLOUT OUTSIDE
OF OUR INTER CONNECTED BODIES
THAT WERE SLOWLY BUT SURELY
HAVING DIALOGUE WITH THEM.
I'M TALKING ABOUT POLICY AND HOW
WE WANT EFFECTUATE THE RIGHT
TYPES OF CHANGES TO SAY HEY IF
YOU PURCHASE THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY RIGHT NOW ARE YOU
GONNA GET COST CONTAINMENT AND
STATE BEST VALUE BUT YOU'RE
GONNA GET THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SECURITY POSTURE. THAT WE CAN
OFFER NOT ONLY TO OUR SECURITY
OPERATIONS CENTER BUT THROUGH
OUR CORE AND FOR SURE.
WERE ALSO AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER STARTING HOW DIALOGUE
WITH CITY AND COUNTY CIO'S ON
HOW THEY CAN LEVERAGE OUR CLOUD
SERVICES.
SO WE HAVING OTHER AYE AYE CLOUD
AYE OF BEER INVITATION FOR A BIT
ON THE STREET RIGHT NOW. AND
WE'RE ASKING THE COUNTY TO COME
PARTICIPATE WITH US DURING
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
VENDORS
SO THERE IS I THINK AN ELEMENT
OF. SINCERITY WITH THE COUNTY
SAW CIO'S AS WELL AS THE EYE OF
SO COMMUNITIES TO START LOOKING
OUT OF STANDARDIZING IT PLATFORM
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
ADDRESSES THE NECESSARY SECURITY
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
GOTTA THANK YOU MISTER LIEBER
YOU'D DO A CITED SOME NUMBERS.
I THINK YOU SAID THAT THERE'S
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED MILLION OF.
THE TAX.
MADEO THEREABOUTS IN IN OF
WHICH A HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND WERE ARE CONSIDERED TO
BE SUSPICIOUS.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING WHETHER.
THE MAJORITY OF THE THE THE
ATTEMPTS.
WERE TARGETING PARTICULAR
SECTORS EXAMPLE WHETHER ITS
FINANCIAL SECTOR.
LET'S SAY THE ELECTION SYSTEM
OR OTHERWISE ANY ANY ANY DUE TO
SEE A TREND AS TO WHAT KIND OF
ATTACKS THAT YOU KNOW OF ALL
THESE ARE. BAD ACTORS ARE.
DOING FOR EXAMPLE ARE THE YOU
KNOW WHAT.
I BELIEVE THAT.
SO I I CAN SAY THAT.
FOR THOSE THAT ARE YOU CAN
UTILIZING SIEGE AND WE HAVE THE
THAT STAT APPLIES NAM. A LOT OF
THE.
.
ATTACKS THAT WE'VE SEEN OUR SO.
WE GIVE THAT STATISTIC THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION.
PER DAY AT SUCH A BLOCKED
ATTEMPTS AND SO.
BECAUSE THEY'RE BLOCKED YOU
WON'T NECESSARILY KNOW WHAT THE
INTENT IS ABOUT THE COMING FROM
SUSPICIOUS SITES TO HAVE THAT
CERTAIN TYPE TRAFFIC PATTERN
THAT IS PROBLEMATIC.
SO WE DON'T EVEN LET HIM
THROUGH THE DOOR IF YOU WELL.
I'M VERY HARD TO GET.
STATISTICS ON THAT BECAUSE WE
WE BALK AT ITS SOURCE.
BOB THE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND.
STATISTIC WHICH IS C. A
SUSPICIOUS EVENTS THAT WE'VE
ANALYZED.
IS THAT'S THE TRAFFIC THAT GETS
TO THE DOOR BUT STILL LOOKS A
LITTLE FUNKY WANNA DO SOME
ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT IT IS.
MALICIOUS.
SO BASED OFF OF THAT.
I WOULD SAY THE THE SPLIT IS.
AYE I'LL HAVE PARTS OF HIS DICK
BUT IT'S IT'S ACROSS THE BOARD
WE SEE.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF EXPLOITS
BEEN ATTEMPTED WE'VE SEEN.
.
SOME KNOWN PAST KNOWN.
EXPLOITS YOU SEE THINGS LIKE
HEART BELIEVE BEING ATTEMPTED.
WHICH IS.
AN OLD VULNERABILITY.
.
YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY ACROSS THE
BOARD AND THE REASON FOR THAT MY
OPINION IS THAT MAJORITY OF THIS
IS AUTOMATED.
ON ITS
YOU KNOW SCRIPTS BEING RUN BY.
YOU KNOW FOLKS OUT THERE AND
DIFFERENT.
EVEN IN THE U. S..
WITH MALICIOUS INTENT.
BETTER JUST HAMMERING AWAY WITH
WHATEVER THEY CAN IF THEY GET A
INDICATOR BACK THAT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT CAN BREAK INTO.
WILL FLIP A SWITCH AND GO FOR
IT.
.
CERTAINLY OTHER ARE SOME
TARGETED ATTACKS.
BUT I DON'T HAVE THE.
SPLIT ON THAT UNFORTUNATELY
TERMS OF STATISTICS
DID YOU SEE ANY ATTACKS ON OUR
OUR VOTING SYSTEM WHATSOEVER
ELECTION VOTING SYSTEM
WHATSOEVER. I'M NOT DOES I TO MY
KNOWLEDGE IT DOES NOT FALL UNDER
THIS YOU GEN NETWORK SO I WOULD
NOT HAVE THOUGHT OF THIS
BUILDING. GOT IT GOT PARED IT
DOWN.
I DON'T HAVE ANYMORE QUESTIONS.
CO CHAIR WHEN YOU HAVE A
QUESTION.
IF THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
YOU GENTLEMEN AS WELL AS THE
PREVIOUS A PANEL AND IT'S BEEN
VERY INFORMATIVE. AND DODGE WE
LOOK FOR TO CAN.
AND OUT.
CUT OFF YEAH BEFORE DISMISS THIS
GROUP I WANTED I WANTED THANK
YOU THANK YOU BEFORE I INVITE
PUBLIC SILICON AND SELL SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE. SO
I WE NEXT GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADJOURNMENT.
ALL WITH THAT PUBLIC COMMENT.
WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO.
SPEAK ON NOW CYBERSECURITY ON
TODAY'S TOPIC TODAY PLEASE US
THAT FOR.
SEEING NONE I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF YOU FOR BEING HERE A
PARTICULARLY THE PRESENTERS AND
UP AS I SAID BEFORE I LOOK FOR
TO WE LOVE FOR TO WORKING. WITH
YOU IN THE YEARS TO COME SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH KEEP UP YOUR
GOOD WORK.
MEETING ADJOURNED